Boom,
and we're live back from Hawaii right
before it fucking blows up and sinks
into the ocean.
Just in time.
Woo.
We barely made it when we were flying
above the big island as we were flying
above.
What's a matter?
Okay.
As we were flying above the big island,
a 6.9 earthquake blew up.
Yeah.
That's not good.
No.
Shane Dorian fucking lives there.
We looked out the window and saw the
island like explode in sync.
I remember that Ad.
That was so sad,
but at least,
I mean we had a good hunt.
People were surfing though.
They caught those waves.
If you're worried about a tsunami,
it's not going to sink,
but it's going to get bigger.
That's what it is.
I mean,
the whole thing is a fucking volcano.
People are shocked.
Weight.
The volcanoes.
Volcano.
Yeah.
You live on a Goddamn volcano.
Oh crap.
I wish it would have been out of fly
over it though.
Yeah.
I was looking at the like the map of
what?
The way we fly.
We fly so we can't see it the entire
way.
Yeah.
Which is bullshit because it was cloudy.
Which is also bullshit.
That would have been cool.
I even asked the guy like,
which way do we go?
Yeah,
that would be fucking awesome if we flew
over that thing.
Yeah.
Ooh,
fuck.
Living on a volcano though,
man.
Good place to visit though is beautiful.
Oh,
stunning.
Yeah.
Great.
And where we were,
we were on Lanai and alumni is an
interesting place.
3000 people,
20,000 deer,
right?
And,
and so you do the math,
you think,
hey,
this is going to be gravy.
There is way more deer than people.
But God it was,
it's tough.
It's tough hunting.
Hunting for sure.
Well this is one of the best examples,
um,
of if you want to make an argument for
hunting like this in certain situations,
this is probably the best example.
You must control the population in these
animals.
They don't have any predators.
And they evolved around tigers.
They come from India.
So these axis deer,
they were a gift from a Hong Kong to
King Kamehameha the fifth.
I saw your history lesson in 1860 and I
was getting it all into it today because
I want to make my post about it as
awesome.
Um,
so they,
what did,
how,
what is the number that they shoot?
How many did they shoot a week?
Just to,
just to people and control.
The population said 1500 but not a week
was it?
No,
I think it was 30 a day.
Oh,
okay.
And they were saying the shoot 30 a day,
right,
because they have to go at night.
Yup.
What's night night vision scopes and
shoot dose.
Yeah.
Just to take them out,
just to take them out.
Does that so many deer when we were
there at night,
um,
we got,
first of all we got,
I got super lucky.
Thanks to you.
You,
you let me take that deer.
Well,
when white one,
we landed,
we went to Scout,
we got out of the car,
we went and looked around and within
five minutes we saw a buck feeding in a
doable spot.
I creeped in.
It was total it w it just gives you a
distorted perception of your
chances of success because for the next
five days I got nothing until the last
day,
but in 15 minutes I got the first deer.
But when you get there,
you realize how switched on these
things.
Like there's,
there's nothing like these things.
It's a,
you know,
I've hunted in Africa,
in the antelope there are pretty quick
also just like that just because of
lions and hyenas and yeah,
just,
just super jumpy,
twitchy.
But in these deers,
very similar,
just quick,
when we were leaving that night when
you,
and me and Adam were in the truck and we
were leaving and we turned the lights on
the truck and you could see hundreds of
deer in front of us.
Yeah.
It was the craziest,
like it was like a crowd being led out
of a concert or something like that or
basketball game,
basketball games over,
cause it is just that they're coming out
of the trees,
um,
crossing the road into the open field
where we'd been hunting and it's just
hundreds.
You can't imagine if you haven't been
there.
You can't imagine if you,
if you move there or if you just went
there for a few days,
you'd kind of get it.
You'd be like,
okay,
what do you do about these things?
Well,
you can't give them birth control.
I mean they eat grass.
So like how are you going to stop them
from breeding?
You're not so what are you gonna do?
You're gonna introduce tigers to Lanai.
That would be cool.
That may be the only way to do it other
than hunters.
And they're going to start eating people
just hunting.
And it's such a destination for just
getting good deer meat.
And I was thinking about it too,
that stretch or are those hundreds of
deer cross the highway?
You know,
that's,
I mean it's a straight as can be.
You can see,
I mean great visibility,
but the speed limit is 35 I think it's
because deer are always jumped out in
front of cars there.
People would be dying.
So it's,
it seems like,
why is it 35 this is like you should be
70 but so many deer.
I think it's also because they're like,
where are you going?
Yeah.
Slow down.
You know,
there's no hurry.
What's the hurry man?
Relax.
I mean,
3000 people on the island.
Maybe that,
yeah,
that's part of it too.
That islands so relaxed and the people
are so friendly.
I was an awesome,
awesome place.
It was a,
um,
anytime I go on a hunt,
I mean,
I'm thankful for the experience and for
seeing the animals,
but also meeting the people,
you know,
Alec,
Bob,
the butcher.
Um,
they're just like these people that are
ingrained in your,
in your memory and you know,
that's it.
That's such a special part of the trip
also.
Yeah,
the experience is very,
very unusual because there's really not
a place like that that I know of
anywhere on the planet that's just a
small island with a small population of
people and a massive population of the
most delicious animals in the world.
And even though there's so many of them,
good fucking luck getting one.
Then we had our friend Ben O'brian,
he went home empty handed.
So one of us in a group of very
experienced hunters.
I mean other than me,
everybody in that group
is super,
super experienced.
Yeah.
You know,
and still is no cake walk.
These things are switched on and they
dodge arrows like during the matrix.
I mean,
it's crazy.
It's a,
there's no gimmie's.
No,
I mean it's a,
you can do everything right.
You can,
you can think in your head.
While I travel all the way here,
I'm,
I'm here to hunt.
I,
I need to take me home.
It doesn't matter those deer,
there's no gimmie's.
They're trying to stay alive and they
know what's up.
They get hunted.
I don't know if it's every day because
when their,
when their antlers fall off,
you know,
the bucks probably are hunted.
But because they're killing doe is at
night.
They're hunted most days out of the
year.
So they are as,
as wired as it can be.
I mean,
because they're,
they're used to being pursued.
Yeah.
It's different than say like whitetail
deer,
like whitetail deer seem to kind of know
when hunting season comes around.
Yeah.
Like when they're velvet drops off and
they rubbed their velvet off and then
the,
the females start coming into season.
That's when they get fucking sketchy and
nervous because they know that guns are
going to be going off.
Yeah,
arrows are going to be flying their way.
Right,
but you catch them during the summer and
then just kind of chilling.
Yeah.
These things are never challenged
polar in the winter after season.
They're just,
they're a more focused on food and
putting on some weight to to make it
through the winter.
So other than hunting season,
they are more chill.
But these things,
I don't think they ever get a day off.
They don't get a day off and they can't
give him a day off because if they just,
if everybody said,
hey man,
let's just need these animals,
and then man,
if they did,
they would all die either of starvation
or they would die.
Like they had to eradicate the goat
population on the island because people
brought goats there and the goats
literally had decimated the vegetation
to the point where the island started
going into a drought.
I don't understand this,
but somehow or another,
if you eat all of the vegetation,
the,
the rain stops falling in certain areas
where there's a lack of participation,
reputation or condensation doesn't
gather because there's no,
no leaves to catch capture it.
Or one of the ladies who lived there was
explaining it to me why they had to kill
all the goats.
Oh,
I see.
And she was like,
trees were dying,
everything was dying.
And they're in the process right now of
a,
in Maui,
they have this gigantic area that they
are trying to eradicate deer from and
they want to fence it in to let the
forest regrow because the forest doesn't
have a chance to regrow with again,
same animal access deer because they
just eat all the little baby trees as a
little trees are coming up,
they just chew those fuckers up and
that's what they eat.
They shoots and they want the new
browse.
Yeah,
yeah.
New Growth.
Yeah.
Well,
it's uh,
I mean as far as our trip goes.
And that was another thing I wanted to
mention too,
is the,
you said the group of people,
Ben was one of them,
but,
uh,
we,
we had just an awesome group of hunters
that are all our friends.
Yeah,
exactly.
And some of the best bell hunters in the
world.
And it was a man.
It a good time
hearing the stories from everybody was.
Yeah.
Uh,
then John Dudley made an amazing meal,
cooked up some meat one night and it's,
is his cooking good man.
Good access dear.
So delicious.
It's incredible.
Yeah.
It goes with my theory that the fastest
things are the most delicious because
they're trying to get away cause they
know they taste good.
Yeah.
Maybe hey,
it might be something to that salmon.
How good is salmon?
They're like,
get me the fuck out of here.
I don't like fish.
But you don't like fish at all?
I like halibut.
I like white white fish.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Um,
Shane,
Shane Dorian,
big wave surfer slash awesome bow
hunter,
Remy Warren,
our buddy Adam Green tree,
uh,
Sam Solo Hall.
Ben O'brien.
Yeah.
Uh,
I don't know.
Will's last name.
We'll from Yeti.
Yeah.
I don't know either.
I don't know.
Yeah,
Nice Guy.
Yeah.
Great Guy.
But I mean,
what a fucking crew.
Yeah.
So awesome.
It was great.
It was a,
and just so much respect for guys like
those guys who are at the top of their
game,
you know what I mean?
But learning,
I don't think people realize how hard it
is.
No.
So when I see these guys go out and
they're successful with basically a
sharp stick,
you know,
it's on,
especially on an animal like that.
So a lot of these people,
it's new country.
Like Adam hadn't been there.
I hadn't,
I had never been there.
Um,
when you see guys go out there and do
that on a new hunt in new country for
new animals,
it's a,
it's impressive.
Well that we really did like,
look at that.
That's the goddamn 18 taken me and kimmy
out of the mix and we'll,
let's be honest,
he got a deer though.
He'd take kit at the,
I'm just fucking with him.
He's a good dude.
Dies.
I mean,
what I'm saying is like you and Dudley
and Adam and remy,
I mean fucking straight assassins and
Shane,
I mean shame and he lives out there,
but people don't know Shane is world
renowned as a big wave surfer,
but he's an awesome bow hunter.
I mean,
he's really excellent and does it all
the time out there.
Spot and stalk,
crawling around the bushes and crawled.
I mean,
you were there the last day when I shot
my last dear,
I crawled a quarter of a mile to get to
these fuckers.
Yeah,
they were up on the hill.
I always watching you guys from an
elevated spot up on top of the hill.
And I was,
I,
when you guys were up walking from a
mile,
I could see you easy,
you know,
I mean binoculars,
no problem.
And then all of a sudden you're gone.
And so I sit Alica Tech.
So I'm like,
why are you guys hiding from me?
Cause I was just like,
you have to really glass really gas and
that'd be like there was a head okay
there head.
Okay now I see you guys.
But it was yeah,
crawling for a long time.
Um,
let me think how long,
I would say an hour almost.
We crawled for an hour,
an hour to get a quarter mile and it,
that is a lot of work.
You know,
you got a bow so you had a bow in your
hand and I didn't have anything.
But you're moving that bow with each.
Yeah.
Whatever you crawling step and in
as basically doing a plank for an hour.
Yeah,
I was,
I was winded by the time we got to where
the deer were and now it's like take a
deep breath,
take a deep breath because we got within
55 yards and I'm like,
we're good right here and this is a good
spot.
We're behind a Bush but it like my
shoulders are sore as I was doing
pushups.
Yeah.
Cause like you're,
you're crawling like a cat,
so you're just,
and you try to be super quiet.
So like if you saw us do it,
people that are listening,
you're crawling but you're not just kind
of crawling along.
You're crawling as quietly as you can.
And Kimmy,
a deep respect for camouflage too.
Like I was wearing a camouflage face
mask and that hat and I had a camouflage
backpack by the final day I had gloves
on,
I was fucking fully cam mode.
We went,
took the shoes off,
we were crawling.
A lot of it was in wool socks just so he
could be even more quiet.
Yeah.
There's,
there's no,
you can't take to greater measures on
being more stealthier quiet on these
animals.
Yeah.
And uh,
immediately I put up the post and,
uh,
I saw one negative comment.
I'm like,
I'm not an,
I'm reading this shit.
One of the things that happened while I
was there,
it was my phone fucked up.
I dropped my phone on the first day and
when I dropped my phone in the first
day,
it just went haywire.
It wouldn't work anymore.
And so I had to get a new phone so I
ordered a new phone and had it shipped
to the island.
And when I was doing that,
I didn't use anything.
I didn't use any APPS.
I didn't check my email,
I didn't check twitter and I felt
better.
I felt better.
He went cold Turkey.
I went cold Turkey for three days and
while I was out there going cold Turkey,
I was like,
I feel better.
Like this is better.
Like checking all that stuff all the
time.
Like,
do I need to know about the Mueller
probe 24 seven do I,
do I need to?
I don't.
What about stormy Daniels?
Do I need to know what the latest stormy
Daniels lawsuit is?
If I was a super billionaire character,
I'd give stormy Daniels money and go,
please stop.
No,
but everybody,
I don't,
I don't want him to hear it.
What do you mean you want money?
You want money?
I'm not even saying that he's not guilty
or that she's,
you know,
she's in the wrong,
I don't think she is.
But what are you looking for?
Let's can we get this out of the news.
I don't need to hear this anymore.
He fucked you.
I get it.
Yeah.
How do people fucked a lot of people
since that time?
You know it's irritating.
What you pay $135,000 like,
okay,
so you're going to just keep it on the
DL,
right?
We're good hundred 35 and then get the
money.
Now she's talking well deals that I
don't think she has that money anymore.
I think she spent it.
Oh,
she needs more money.
I'm like,
she needs more money and I think she
realizes this is an opportunity for,
you know,
I don't know how to look at it because
on one hand I'm like,
well,
I think we should hold the president up
to higher standards and you,
you shouldn't be able to just lie all
the time and be the president because
how could we trust you if it comes to
something serious,
like a warm war with China or some
something crazy or invading Iran.
Let's just go off the charts with
craziness.
Yeah.
I gotta be able to trust you with
everything.
If I can't trust you that you,
you don't want to tell everybody that
you banged a porn star.
Wouldn't it be great if he just had a a
press conference in Ladies Gentlemen?
Who Cares?
Yeah.
I,
I enjoy sex.
I'm a heterosexual man.
Millennia,
10 years before he was elected or
whatever,
it was like,
I shouldn't have fucked this porn star,
but I couldn't help myself.
I'm a pig,
but I'm doing a good job as a president.
The economy is up.
Unemployment the town.
Thank you.
Good night.
Support the troops,
troops,
port,
the NRA.
Hey,
here's the,
I'm paying.
So you say you can't trust them because
if you lie about this stuff,
but,
okay,
so you say another president,
how do you know they're not lying?
They are lying.
Yeah.
So
I think deval lied.
I think,
look,
one of the things that,
you know,
I had a conversation with a friend of
mine about a Hillary Clinton and he's a,
he's a big Hillary Clinton supporter to
the point where it's like,
he like Jamie with the cavaliers hat on,
he might as well have a Hillary Clinton
hat on.
He's like a Hillary Clinton says,
I'm sure they do.
I'm sure they had them right.
I'm with her.
This guy is a,
him and his wife are both like Super
Hillary supporters and I'm like,
it doesn't bother you at all that she
deleted 30,000 emails.
So it doesn't bother you at all.
Like they told her there's a probe,
we need to see all your emails,
just deleted them all.
That doesn't bother you.
Like that doesn't seem like maybe she's
a liar.
And then when you hear,
call me his account of what happened
versus her account of what happened.
She's clearly not being honest.
That doesn't bother you.
And he's like,
well,
I think in comparison she doesn't apply
as much.
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
Like these are lies.
It doesn't matter in comparison.
Right.
So my point is,
I think anybody who gets to that level
of that business is slimy and one way or
another,
everyone's slimy
maybe.
But we would like you to not be,
yeah,
it'd be great.
We'd like everybody to not be,
yeah,
he,
I dunno.
I think the only way to get to the
bottom of it is get him on the podcast.
I would love to get him on the podcast.
I'll have to get them drunk.
He doesn't drink.
That's,
oh,
that's what I was wondering.
So you know,
most people have podcasts that aren't
the,
almost the Joe Rogan,
but that's almost true right now.
Like most people do have podcasts and
no,
I know,
but,
well,
okay,
now let me finish.
So most people that do,
they'd be like,
they got this,
get this a dream guest list.
You know,
the,
the wishlist and these are my,
I'd love to have these people.
And I was thinking about you,
it's like it seems like,
and I don't know,
I'm not you,
but like the Courtney to Walter,
the people you're interested in are more
important to you than say like the Ala,
the like uh,
the president United States.
I mean,
so how do you,
do you have a wishlist of I don't have
a wishlist.
No,
no.
We were talking about this on the plane
ride.
I don't,
I like talking to my friends.
Yeah,
I like talking to you.
Yeah.
I like talking to interesting people
like the sleep expert hat on the all the
day Matthew Walker or pete you didn't
like,
and he's telling me he sleeps three
hours a night,
so I didn't like that.
So I'm going to ignore him that you said
that.
That guy,
oh,
you Monday we have Michael Chandler.
I'm looking forward to that.
I like,
I like talking to interesting people and
they don't have to be famous to me at
all right now.
Some of my favorite podcasts for people
that aren't famous at all.
Yeah.
Just like people that are interesting.
I mean that's obviously a pretty blanket
statement,
but I like people that are doing things
that are unique,
people that are,
that are like masters at a craft.
People that are working hard,
people that inspire me.
I like to be inspired,
you know,
like I like talking to people who are
curious and who've studied things,
you know,
whether it's Sean Carroll or Neil
degrasse Tyson or people that understand
things that I don't understand so I can
pick their brain and ask them questions
about stuff.
That to me is interesting,
but trump habits sitting down with
trump.
But B to me like a lot like sitting down
with my friend Alex Jones,
like it's,
it'd be like,
okay,
like it would be the best I would be
like if you talked to him for three
hours,
what kind of crazy stuff would come out?
It'd be awesome.
I really think that if he wasn't
president,
I would like him.
I would really,
I would like him,
I would think.
I would think he's a character if I
didn't have business to do with him
where I was worried about like,
you know,
getting screwed over in some sort of a
deal or something like that.
I would like him cause I would think
he's a wild man and he's a character.
He's a fucking seven year old dude with
the crazy fucking hair.
He wears a red bat baseball hat
everywhere that says make America great
again.
That's awesome.
You can't even wear that hat in the
bars.
Could you imagine that?
He is so divisive.
Like he's so the people are so
conflicted.
One side of the other against him that
if you wear that hat they will kick you
out of places.
Yeah.
What world do we live in?
Yeah,
well you can't wear something that says
make America great again.
Yeah.
How,
how could that be considered?
Anything but positive.
How's,
I don't understand.
But he's,
people hate him so much and that's,
so,
that's,
to me even a great accomplishment from
what he's done is like,
he's got so much hate and he's still
look at all the positives that happen.
Well,
most people don't think any positives
that happened because if most people in
my most people,
I think there has been,
well,
I think most people live in an echo
chamber and if you're like my friend
who's a giant Hillary Clinton supporter,
all you hear is trust the devil.
And you know,
he was like completely convinced that it
was going down and trump's going to be
kicked out of office in the first 60
days and he's like,
trust me,
it's not going to last a year.
I'm like,
A year later he's crying and he's
fucking pulling his hair out.
It's
going crazy.
You know,
like Marie Keith Olbermann?
Yeah,
he's open and he,
he retired that show.
He's like,
yeah,
I don't need to do this anymore.
It's just a matter of days.
That was fucking six months ago I think.
When did he,
when did he quit the resistance?
It was,
it wasn't soon enough.
I think he just had to fucking take a
break.
I think he was losing his marbles,
but they're so interested in the
negative narrative that they're not,
they won't even promote anything
positive.
So it's like when he was saying all the
rocket man stuff,
it's like,
oh,
trump's going to cause a nuclear war.
Okay,
now he's talking and now they're in
negotiations with North Korea and south,
north and south are talking and he's
like,
ah,
trump had nothing to do with it.
It's like,
well,
how could he almost our nuclear war and
then have nothing to do with what's
going on?
It's like it can't be both.
Right?
Well I guess it probably could if they
were like,
listen,
let's not start a nuclear war.
How about what you and I talk like north
and South Korea,
so let's get together and figure this
out.
This crazy ass hole on the other side of
the country or the world rather than,
okay,
so he's,
he deserves credit for that sense of
respect.
He's very,
he's a very interesting guy and the fact
that his methods are so outrageous and
outside the norm,
then I don't think these world leaders
know what the fuck to do with him when
he gets calling him rocket man.
I know my buttons bigger than yours.
What?
Yeah,
what's,
he says crazy shit.
He says crazy shit,
but that's what he's always done.
Yeah.
So it's,
he's consistent.
We just expect them to do something
different because he's the president
right now your working,
we were talking about this on the plane
too,
that you're working with.
What is your,
your position in the administration
because you actually have a wildlife
conservation position now in the
government.
Right.
Did you ever fucking thing that was
going to happen?
No.
No,
I didn't know.
How the hell did this even come up?
Oh God.
Um,
I dunno.
I'm on the International Wildlife
Conservation Council.
Whoa.
Yeah,
that's legit.
It's a hell of,
I got a business and I don't have a
business card,
but if I did,
did you get a belt buckle for that?
I should.
Oh,
I was thinking about the belt buckle.
So I then I was like,
I was like,
he said,
you said you wanted a belt buckle.
And I'm like,
oh maybe I'll give them my belt buckle
that I wore on the hunt.
But then I'm thinking,
so,
so I gave you the belt buckle,
but then I'm like,
shit,
maybe he wants a new belt buckle.
Oh No.
In the box with the sweet custom box.
No,
no,
no.
I didn't want it to be disrespectful on
Tryna say here's a huge belt.
You know the,
we'll use one was blood on it.
Yeah,
it does.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Look it.
Okay.
I just want her,
I want her to make sure you're good with
that.
Cause I wasn't,
I just want,
I want you to want or get what you want
basically.
Um,
so international law of Conservation
Council,
so I,
I dunno how it started cause I'm like,
man,
there are some powerful people on their
safari club,
international people,
a super successful business people in
and a political campaign type
contributors.
And then,
you know,
we go to this meeting,
there's 16 of us on the couch and just
like this cowboy boots,
flannel shirt,
just like this dude,
this and everybody else is wearing a
suit and dies.
And I'm like,
do they give you grief for dressing like
that?
Not to my face,
but maybe later fucking Oregon
Hillbilly.
That's probably,
and uh,
so yeah,
I don't know.
I don't know why I'm on there.
I don't who contacted you?
Um,
or the interior department.
So like you're in the middle of a run
running a mount.
Pisgah yeah,
no,
I got to call Washington DC.
She,
I'm fuck up.
Swear to God.
And I'm like,
oh my God,
this the be good.
Cause it was after.
Okay,
so trump put out the tweet and he said
something like,
he doesn't see how hunting for elephants
is conservation or,
or helps wildlife.
It's a,
it's a horror show.
Doesn't know elephants or any other
animal,
something like that.
And I was like,
what in the hell is that?
What are we talking about?
You know,
elephants talk about elephants,
that's fine.
Whatever.
But he said,
or any other animal.
So I took that tweet,
I posted it and addressed it.
And I don't know if he saw it,
I don't really know.
But soon after that I got a call for
this thing.
And so,
cause I was,
you know,
I know just from had in Africa and how
it works.
And,
um,
the hunting is necessary over there if
the animals are going to survive,
if,
if that's a complicated story.
It's a complicated situation,
but people,
uh,
people don't want to hear that now.
So here's an example of in Tanzania
there was a,
the largest hunting concession,
and I'm trying to think how big it was.
I,
I can't put the number on how big it
was,
but they'd been in business for 40
years.
So a hunting concession is,
is they have,
you know,
hunters from,
usually America go over there.
They pay for the,
for the access to the land and they pay
for the right to hunt these animals.
So this place had been in business for
40 years.
Um,
they went out of business because of
this import ban.
Obama put an import ban on the ivory of
elephants coming back as trophies,
but also bottom lines,
the line thing was right after cecil the
lion and it was done as a political
measure,
right?
So he put a ban on,
you can go over there and hunt him.
Still it cause you know,
we're from America,
we can't say what's legal in Africa,
but he can say what he did was say we
can hunt them whatever because they
can't control that,
but you can't bring them home.
So nobody's going to go and spend 75,000
kill an elephant or 50,000 to kill a
lion if they can't bring it home.
Right.
So that basically shut down hunting and
um,
this outfit in Tanzania that had
business business for 40 years,
they,
cause they went out of business about,
I think it's about two months ago now.
And what happens is when they don't have
the,
the concession,
they can't pay for that land.
It is given back to the people.
And for us here,
there'll be like,
oh,
that's great you gave the land back to
the people.
No,
it's not good to give the land back to
the people there because if people can't
do anything,
you don't have any money there.
They don't just like,
so what happens is a poacher is as soon
as the hunting concession moves out,
poachers move in and kill every animal.
The only reason the animals that were
being protected in that hunting
concession was because there was hunting
in there.
These,
this outfit would spin,
I think in the last three years they
spent over $2 million on anti poaching
efforts.
So $2 million to protect basically their
investment,
which is those animals that were in
there.
Yeah,
they'd kill a couple because,
because,
um,
elephants were haunted and they ran the
Ha's and probably lions.
But by and large,
they're protecting the majority of the
herd.
Well,
give me,
give me those numbers again because you
were,
you were giving me the numbers on
elephants legally and illegally.
Right.
So,
so,
and I asked this back at our first
international wildlife conservation
council meeting and this,
you know,
Peter was there and all these animal
rights activists,
um,
I don't want to say psychos that could
be disrespectful,
but anyway,
these extremists were there and so it
was kind of heated in some point,
some cases.
But I did ask this question,
how many elephants are killed legally in
Africa each year?
And the number is about 400,
400 a kid legally.
The entire continent.
Yeah.
So g area so big that you can get
America,
the United States of America,
you can also get all the European
countries.
You could fit a lot of shit in Africa.
Africa is huge,
huge place.
Yeah.
And so there's some,
there's some areas where you're not
going to hunt elephants because there's
not,
there's not enough or um,
they don't live there.
But there are some areas where there's
too many elephant.
It's,
it's just,
yeah,
that's what's confusing to be where
people here,
elephants are going extinct.
Well,
yeah,
they are in some places.
And then another places.
The problem is with local farmers,
they have these plots of land and the
elephants come in and eat everything and
destroy their land and they can't do
anything about it.
And what are you going to do this?
How the,
how big is an elephant?
How many thousands of pounds?
10,000 pounds or some shit.
I don't even know.
They're huge.
They're huge,
but they don't do a goddamn thing about
care about elephants.
They don't.
They're like,
the elephant is ruining my crop.
Yeah.
That's what I need to eat.
I'm going to kill the elephant.
It's going to lay there and rot.
Yeah.
There's these,
these people are starving.
I mean there,
there's a food chain going on there and
humans here where we are,
we're,
we're so far above the food chain that
we're like sitting in a platform looking
down,
watching it.
They're,
they're embedded in it.
There on
level.
They'll in there,
it's,
it's the whole,
it's a whole analogy of you can't have
first world world people solving third
world problems and it's just,
we,
people here have all the answers.
It's like you have everything you want.
You have,
you live in excess,
you're fat,
you have,
you throw food away.
What are you talking about?
Do you have no idea what it's like in
Africa?
So they're 400 elephants are killed
legally.
30,000 are poached a year,
30,000 and the reason that's happening
is because the hunting had to move out.
The hunting closed down or hunting is
what pays for the anti poaching efforts,
but when hunting money isn't there,
the poachers run rampant 30,000
elephants.
That's why they are devastated.
It's such a not hunting.
It's such a hard thing for people to
swallow because what this is from the
point of view of someone who loves
wildlife,
I think this is what people want.
What they want is the humans to leave
the animals alone and the animals to
live in this state of bliss where they
exist perfectly,
and the balance of nature of Predator
and prey all plays out in a natural way
without people going over there and
shooting elephants than sticking their
tusks on their wall.
Yeah.
I mean we've all seen those pictures of
these giant fat fucks holding a rifle
standing over a lie and you're like,
this just looks wrong.
Yeah.
It looks like American gluttony makes
its way over to Africa and some guy
shoots a line with a rifle.
Now he's standing on its head and he's
going to put it on his wall and it's fat
fucking house somewhere that bothers
people.
I get,
I get it too.
I mean,
I'm not arguing that,
but,
but you got to fix Africa first and you,
you're not trying.
So this idea that if you just leave all
those animals alone and stop hunting
them,
everything's going to be fine.
No,
they're going to be wiped out.
You got to,
people have to look at it pragmatically
first and then idealistically.
Cause pragmatically you have to
understand that these animals,
20 years ago,
we're on the verge of extinction.
So many different antelopes,
so many different what we'd call game
animals,
animals that people eat.
We're on the verge of extinction until
they started instituting these big
hunting concessions and having people
come in from Europe and America and
hunting in Africa.
Then the community started to prosper
because if someone's paying,
you know,
I don't know how much is it to shoot
like a,
uh,
a neil guy or something like that,
maybe 1500.
So think of how many of those things get
shot.
And some of that money goes to the
ranch.
Some of that money goes to the
professional hunting guys,
anti poaching conservation efforts,
and then you have unprecedented numbers.
There's more of those animals today than
there have been in decades.
And it's all because people put value on
them.
Yeah.
It's all about the animals have to have
value and people will say,
no will,
the animal has value being alive.
It's like,
okay,
well it does to you.
It starts to you.
If you don't live over there,
if you're not pouring,
your children aren't starving to death.
A picture of an of a line is amazing.
Okay.
And that animal is beautiful.
There's value in being alive,
but he got to understand those people
need to eat,
they need to work.
So if they're not,
we're working for the hunting
concession.
If the Huntington session goes out of
business,
like the largest one in Tanzania did
after 40 years,
what are they going to do?
They can't go get a job at the mill,
you know what I mean?
There's no,
there's not industry over there.
So what happens is as they would,
some of those people,
and I don't know for a fact,
but I would,
I'm going to make an educated guess if
they would go from working as anti
poetry and officers are or are helping
keep the animals alive is as part of the
anti poaching program.
Straight to poaching.
Yeah.
Well that,
that's happened back and forth both
ways,
right?
Yeah.
Former poachers became anti poaching
officers when the opportunity.
Right.
And they were great ones because they
knew how,
how it worked and they knew where the
weaknesses were were and that saved
animals.
But it's just like,
it's,
it's sad because that,
you know,
that last two months without that
hunting concession there without the
anti-poaching,
um,
program in place,
I guarantee it's been a slaughter.
The animals that were being protected
are now just being slaughtered by
poachers.
And again,
the difference between looking at things
pragmatically and looking at things
idealistically,
we would like all those people in Africa
to have plenty of food and plenty of
opportunity for employment and plenty of
things to do with their life,
but they don't.
Yeah.
You know,
and the,
the situation that had emerged with
these hunting sessions is superior to
the situation that's in place now.
And it's also superior for the animals
themselves,
including the lions in Zimbabwe.
They had to kill,
look this up Jamie,
see if you could,
cause they had to call,
I think it was something along the lines
of 200 lions recently because they had
decimated the undulate population
because there weren't kept in check
because the,
Angela,
the way these,
the balance of nature works out is you
have to have a balance between Predator
and prey.
The only way to keep the balance of
Predator as humans.
That's it.
It's the only thing that exists unless
they keep,
yeah.
Zimbabwe,
loud,
rive reserve.
We'll call 200 lines to control a
population explosion.
Claiming hunters have been scared off by
the outcry over seas of the line.
The whole thing is so weird because what
people just jump on it.
You know that you watched the lion king.
Oh Simba.
No,
don't kill Simba and oh see,
so he's got a name and all this
craziness.
It got to such a weird point where there
was this discussion about Cecil's
brother that Cecil's brother got killed
Jericho and they were like,
oh my God,
they killed Jericho.
And then people were relieved because
they found it.
It was a different line and it wasn't
Cecil's brother Jericho.
So this is like,
they're watching it goddamn reality
show.
It's like keeping up with the
Kardashians in Africa.
Like will you give a shit?
What the fucking name of the APP the
African lion is?
You're crazy.
It's not Jericho.
Oh,
it's,
it's Michael the lion.
So it's okay.
That's crazy.
Still a fucking lion.
But this shows you this first world view
of
this wildlife situation that is not
ideal by any stretch of the imagination.
I think part of it,
like with that the whole Cecil lion
thing,
it gave people a purpose as like,
oh,
I have something to stand for.
I have a purpose now.
And that's where I know people are
struggling out there finding what's my
purpose,
what am I doing?
You know,
and they're spinning their wheels.
They don't,
I dunno what they do,
but that gave them something to fight
for and it wasn't right.
It didn't help anything.
It hurt those 200 lions could have been
$50,000 each to a hunter.
$10 million or two went to Zimbabwe,
stayed there or,
or at least employed people.
But no,
they were killed in,
there was no game.
Yeah,
it still sucks all across the board.
It's sucks.
The whole situation sucks.
These weird high fence operations where
they let lions loose and then they let
him out of the cage and then people show
up that day and the lines on what the
fuck's going on and they shoot this
line.
And then stand up.
That sucks too.
Yeah,
I don't like that.
The whole thing is weird.
It's not look wildlife in Africa and the
high fence wildlife,
it's not ideal by any stretch of the
imagination and these animals that were
going extinct and now aren't because
people were hunting them.
It's fucking strange.
That's a strange balance that the only
reason they exist is so people can come
over there and shoot him.
Like we don't,
I don't,
I don't want that.
I mean I would like them to just exist.
Well the thing,
yeah,
but people aren't going to contribute
that money to pay for the anti poaching
just to go take a picture.
It's like if you go to happen,
if you go to the Missouri breaks or
something like that and you go hunting
mule deer like those,
that's what I like.
I like animals that exist because they,
their,
they're their,
this is their spot.
This is where they are.
Like if you go to the Missouri breaks
and you go up into those those hills and
look for for mule deer,
those fuckers have been there for
thousands of years.
I mean,
they have found skulls of deer of
whitetail deer in Florida that are 2
million years old,
right?
They're the exact same animal 2 million
years ago,
so for millions of years longer than
there have been human beings,
those things have been in that form
running around North America and
wherever the fuck they can.
That's what I like.
I like that too,
but don't forget that hunting has played
a part in keeping those numbers healthy.
Joe,
the deer and the elk,
there's more deer.
There's no big game animal in north.
The big game animals in North American
now than there were a hundred years ago,
and that's through hunting and
conservation.
That is true,
but it's also because 150 years ago,
people went,
fucking ham wiped out.
Most of them.
It was real bad when the market hunting
before refrigeration.
Exactly.
Yeah.
But we've learned from that.
We learn,
okay,
this is how,
this is how we need to do it.
This is how hunting fits in this
equation.
And that's where,
you know,
we talked about the intro National
Wildlife Conservation Council.
That's given me a a way in to talk about
a bunch of other things too.
So one of those,
and we talk about animals in North
America is a Ryan Zinky who is the
secretary of Interior.
He created this new,
I guess it's a bill.
I'm not like this political expert.
I'm about hunger,
right?
I wear a flannel shirt and baseball hat,
but he did create this,
uh,
um,
I'm going to call it a bill,
but that protects the,
the winter that we call them wildlife
corridor.
So it's where the animals can go from
December,
some arrange to winter range where
there's not going to be development
there.
So He created that because that's how
those animals like in Montana,
make it through the winter if they're up
in the summer.
Um,
they make it through,
um,
getting in the fall and then all of a
sudden winter hits,
they have to have a way down into the
low country to where they can their
winter migration to where they can
survive the snow and,
and where they can make down.
And there's good feed down there.
If there's gas rigs or mineral mineral
extraction efforts going on that impede
that,
then they might get hung up up there and
get stuck in the snow and die.
So he realizes that he realized the need
for that and he created this,
this new program that's going to make
sure that there's no development in
there.
It keeps those corridors open and
that's,
that's why our numbers do so well is
because there's people like that with
the vision on keeping our animals
healthy.
Well,
this is another thing that we talked
about,
uh,
on the flight that I think is important
to bring up.
Remember when there was this talk about
the state monument or the National
Monument in Utah and a Patagonia put
that thing on their page.
The president stole your land.
Yeah.
Explain what actually happened because
it's not what everybody thinks it is.
And,
and Rinella said it best if you say the
president stole your land,
you're not being accurate with your
words.
That's not what happened.
It was
Patagonia did an awesome marketing job I
made and that there was efforts by
saying the present sold your land form.
What I've heard,
it resulted in a 15% increase in
business for them.
So it worked great.
But with the truth is,
is a lot of people felt like Obama when
he,
before he left office did um,
and overreach on the national monument
protection.
And so there's protecting the national
monument and then which has a certain
area he protected,
he wanted,
it encompassed 2 million acres in that
national monument designation,
which seems excessive.
What Zinky says,
the secretary of Interior,
he went in there and he said,
that's an excessive,
that's an overreach.
I want to scale it back to what it was
before Obama did and
did that.
Now why is it excessive though?
This is what gets confusing to people.
People think that protecting land is
never accessive,
right?
What he wants to do is make sure people
have access and what,
and it's like,
okay,
so what's the difference between the Wa
the way it is
under Obama and the way it is under
Zinky?
It'll be Zinky scale it back to what it
was before,
which that would be,
it's still national forest still federal
land.
But you'd be able to,
and I'm not sure if it,
if it was wilderness or how the access
would be w,
but what Zinky would say is that like I
would be able to go into the land all
the time,
that 2 million acres,
because I might be considered by some to
be elite,
you know,
because I can walk for 20 miles.
Not Everybody in the United States can
walk 20 miles to get somewhere.
So they want to put road systems.
There's road systems already,
systems already,
but wants to maintain the roads.
So,
but if it was a national monument,
right then no road system.
It's like what is the difference that I
think the road systems would be gated
off and it'd be walking,
walking on foot track traffic only
instead of access through the roads.
Now why did Obama make it 2 million
acres and close off the roads?
I'm not sure.
So it's still federal land.
So it's not like the government sold the
land off now and no mining permits have
been issued and there's no plans to
drill or anything like that?
No.
When I,
when I looked that up because I was
unsure about it and I talked with Zinky
about it just because it's like,
you know,
I'm learning all this as we go also.
And I was concerned when when I read the
president's told your Atlanta,
I'm like,
what's this about?
Um,
and so,
uh,
what,
what it is is what he,
what zinc he wants to do is he wants to
just make sure people have not all
abilities.
Cause it's not like we want roads on
every mountain but have access to two
national forests.
So people that can drive in four by
fours,
you know,
those little off unexisting.
Yeah,
on existing roads and it's just like
national forest now,
national force now has roads,
right,
right.
Designated wilderness areas.
Because then I talked about that too.
I'm like,
well,
okay,
I understand.
I understand access.
I said,
that's great.
I want people to be able to enjoy the
great outdoors also.
But I also grew up hunting the Eagle cap
wilderness,
which is Oregon's largest wilderness
area,
356,000 acres of no roads.
And I don't want roads in there.
I don't want access in the middle of the
heart of that wilderness because some of
the most pristine,
beautiful country in the lower 48 I like
it like that.
So we still need to build to protect
those areas.
But this wasn't in this one.
This is bears ears and,
and Utah.
This wasn't changing anything,
opening up anything or this big
nefarious plan of,
of mining and stripping everything out.
Right,
right.
They were.
But all I did is they went back to what
it was before.
And at that time when our research that
there had been no mining permits,
that from what I understand is there is
no mineral,
there's not an,
there's minerals in there,
but not enough to warrant going in there
and setting up a full mural extraction
mine.
So the building,
the reason that they changed
the distinction is to allow people to
have more access to that wilderness
through roads that already exists.
It wouldn't be wilderness.
It'd be national forest.
Okay.
The federal lands.
Yeah.
So why,
why the uproar then?
Like why is everybody so confused?
Is it a lack of communication?
Is it a lack of understanding about what
the difference in the distinctions of
the two things are?
Uh,
it,
it's just creating a,
you know,
a negative narrative.
It's sane.
It's something changed,
you know,
Obama had at this way,
uh,
Zinky scaled it back,
that right there.
It's like,
why?
What's going on?
Not really doing the research about,
he's not,
he's just putting it back to what it was
because he thought that it was an
overreach by Obama.
So it's just,
you know,
these,
these outfits,
they're in business.
Um,
you know,
if everything's going good,
there's really no reason for people to
get fired up and contribute money.
You know,
some of these,
some of these it's political in some
respects,
businesses,
political.
Um,
it's
very cynical though.
I,
I see what you're saying,
but I think that really what's going on
is people are very concerned and they
see any movement check,
concern.
Yeah.
But even the businesses like Patagonia's
businesses about the outdoors,
that's their whole business.
So they see anything that's changed in
the trump administration,
especially in,
in the beginning when it came in,
people were really worried about them in
terms of environmental concerns,
right?
Because they had opened up offshore
drilling.
They had done a lot of things that
people were really freaked out about.
They had opened up,
what was the area,
Jamie in Alaska where they were going to
open up drilling that was near a salmon
runs that people were very,
very concerned about.
They're were concerned about the idea of
money above nature like and then me to
right.
And who's making that money?
You're not making money.
I'm not making any of that money.
So someone else is going to make money
off of what's supposed to be our land
and our public land,
which you and I could maybe go,
even though you don't like salmon,
we could go salmon fishing in this land.
Well,
it could get fucked up by someone else
making billions of dollars in oil or
natural gas or whatever the fuck we do.
If they contaminate that.
I don't want that.
No,
I don't want,
you don't want that either.
And the people from Patagonia,
So when they see something like this
come up there,
red flags go up.
They want to get people outraged.
They want to get people activated
because they think that they might be a
chance that if you protest enough,
you can stop something like this
happening before it does.
Because if you do look at like what
happened in Alaska with that big oil
spill in the 80s or what happened with
the BP oil spill in the Gulf coast,
like that shit's devastating.
Yeah.
When something like that does happen,
someone else is profiting making fucking
billions of dollars while our,
our planet that we all share is getting
fucked up.
You're not making a nickel off of it.
I'm not making a nickel off of it.
They're making billions of dollars and
they're fucking up the land and by the
government,
by trump or anybody else,
whoever's opening it up,
giving them access to drill,
right
to do all this thing,
you open up the possibility of ruining
something.
That's amazing.
Well.
So there's always going to be a balance
though.
There's,
you can't just say,
okay,
nobody can drive past this point
forever.
You know what I mean?
There's always so,
but you're saying that about the Eagle
cap wilderness,
you don't want them,
there's gotta be areas,
there's gotta be areas we have to
protect wilderness areas.
But for example,
where we've elk hunting in Colorado,
right?
Big Bowls,
awesome elk hunting.
There's natural gas wells all over,
right?
That's great.
Elk Hunting.
Yeah,
they've got,
there's a bowel.
They're not,
yeah,
they're not fucking it up.
So yeah,
I don't want things wiped out in a,
in a huge mineral extraction mine where
there's used to be beautiful,
whatever,
right.
Don't want that.
But ever is it a polluted right now?
But you can't just say,
we're not doing anything anywhere.
It doesn't work.
So there can be a balance just like
where are we have hunted in Colorado.
There can be a balance,
but the real concern that the average
person has,
me included is that someone is going to
profit.
And by doing that we're where it's not
going to benefit you or anybody.
We know it's going to fuck it up for
everybody else.
Yeah.
That's the real concern.
For sure.
I know.
That's why I've tried to,
you know,
that's what I've wanted to be involved.
Like I'm on that council,
which has nothing to do with public
lands in North America,
but it's given me a way to get in there
and try to learn more.
That's all I'm trying to do.
But you also were involved with it when
Jason Chaffetz had that proposal in Utah
to sell off public land,
public land.
You were one of the people that sat down
with him and got his take on it.
And ultimately because the outcry from
people who love the outdoors and hunters
and fishermen,
that was stopped.
Yeah,
it was very interesting.
And that Jason,
he took a lot of shit,
but he seems like a very reasonable guy.
I think so too.
It's um,
you know,
he's out of politics now.
What is he doing?
He's on Fox News.
Oh,
he's a correspondent.
Yeah.
He's so,
he's completely,
he was a congressman out of Utah and I
went back to DC and talk to talk to him.
That was hr six,
22 and that was,
they wanted to sell what they determined
disposable public land.
And I'm like,
okay,
wait a second.
Who says what's disposable?
Cause what's disposable to you?
Might not be to me.
Maybe it's a great hunting area.
So I didn't really,
like,
there wasn't really a way to determine
what was disposable.
That's what caught my attention and
other,
not just mine,
but even people like Steve Rinella in a
lot of people in a loop and in the know.
And I got advice from,
um,
let's see,
Randy Nuber,
stever Nela,
Joel Webster at the,
uh,
Theater,
Roosevelt concert,
uh,
conservation conservation program.
All those guys are really experts in the
field.
Back country hunters and anglers.
I didn't talk to them.
I did was people were super active,
right?
Getting people to complain and protest
this.
And so that one that I did get a chance
to go back there and I did a podcast
with a [inaudible] and yeah,
he pulled it.
It was gone.
Never happen.
But yes,
that's,
I mean we just need to be educated on it
and I just don't like the,
the,
I dunno without that education jumping,
jumping in on the bandwagon and saying,
yeah,
the president stole my land.
It's like what is that even true?
Well,
you know,
I always defer to Rinella when it comes
to things like this because he's so well
versed in it.
So when he said that you're not being
accurate with your words,
I had to look into it deeper,
but I didn't really understand it
totally until I was talking to you and
you were explaining to me the
distinction between how it was before
Obama was in office at Obama changed and
then bringing it back to how it was
before.
So it's still federal land.
No one's sold it off and it's not,
it's just giving people more access to
roads,
but amazing how when something like that
happens,
this is gigantic outcry and everybody
freaks out.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's confusing.
It can be confusing cause I'll read two
different things and I'll be like,
God,
what is it this or is it that's going
on?
I don't know.
Yeah.
So that's where I,
you know,
when people say,
oh well Zinky he was lying to your face.
I'm like,
ah,
I don't know,
maybe
on video.
You had doubt it.
I don't,
he doesn't seem like that guy.
He,
he seems like he's a straight shooter.
You know,
I asked him about,
he was getting beat up because the
national parks advisory board wouldn't,
he wouldn't meet with them.
That's what it was.
And so he got said,
you know,
Zeke,
he doesn't care about national parks and
he won't meet with the advisory board.
And,
and so I asked him about that because
that was in the news and that was just
like,
man,
he,
maybe he doesn't care about public land,
you know,
I mean,
I didn't know what was going on,
so I wanted to ask them about that.
I'm like,
well,
they resigned in protest because you
wouldn't meet with him.
What was that?
And he goes,
well yeah,
you're right.
I wouldn't meet with them.
He goes,
here's how it went.
I came in as secretary of interior and
in charge of,
I don't know how many different
councils,
just like the international one I'm on
in this park advisory board,
that what we're talking about.
And there's I think 200 and some that
he's,
he really,
I think he over,
I don't even thousands of employees,
billions of dollars.
And all he asked was for these advisory
boards.
He wanted,
um,
a report written up that said,
what have you done in the last two
years?
What are you working on now and what's
your goals for the next two years?
Once you provide me with that report,
then I'll get up to speed and I'll meet
with you.
They never did it.
So he didn't meet with them and that was
it.
That said,
the story was he,
he wouldn't meet with them and they
resigned in protest,
but the other half of the story was he
asked him to do something so he could
get up to speed and be educated on
what's going on.
And he never supplied it.
Well if they are the typical government
employees and what is the typical
government employee?
Incompetent.
Lazy.
I'm a government,
but what are we typical?
Oh,
what do people think of,
they think of incompetent,
lazy,
entitled bureaucrats and they've got
this job and like all of a sudden he's
asking them to provide,
not just tell them what they've done,
but tell them what they're going to do
and provide like a framework for the
future.
That makes,
that's a lot of work.
Yeah.
When someone's a lazy fuck if he was
just kind of half ass in your job,
it's just showing up.
And I'm not saying they are.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I didn't know him.
Also,
they might have resented him for
whatever their preconceived notions of
who he is coming into this job.
And they were,
I don't know if all 12 of them,
I think there's 12 I don't,
but I think they were all democrat.
Oh son of a bitches.
So I mean obviously he's a Republican.
He's,
he's gone unpaid volunteers also unpaid
run paid volunteers.
Yeah.
And that's,
I'm,
I'm an unpaid volunteer on that council.
It's like you don't do this for money.
You do it to make a difference.
Yeah.
But if they're going to be a volunteer,
even if there are unpaid volunteer and
if he asks you to have a plan,
you should probably have a plan.
Yeah.
Otherwise,
why have,
why are you doing it?
Because I guarantee you there's someone
out there that would have a plan.
Yeah.
And especially when it comes to
something that's important as national
parks and public land,
things that are like really dear and
important to people is this,
this is something that you,
you know,
you want to have whoever these
volunteers are,
if you're going to appoint them,
you want to have the best ones for the
job.
Right.
So it's asking someone to write a plan
up and that's,
if that's the only reason.
See it's tough because we don't have
their take on it.
Well,
I've,
I read what they wrote and what did they
write?
You just said that he wouldn't meet with
him and whatever.
So he wouldn't read,
meet with them until they did what he
asked.
They didn't say that.
He told me that,
but that's what he says.
Yeah.
Well that makes sense.
I mean,
I'm kind of in his camp,
that's a,
if we're looking at it 100% accurately.
Yeah,
no.
And he told me face to face,
that's what happened.
So I mean,
you know,
you can say,
well,
I don't believe anybody,
I don't believe,
I don't believe what you just told me.
I don't believe that at some point you
have to be like,
man,
it seemed like he was telling me the
truth and I believe it.
And that makes sense.
Yeah.
It does make sense that they would not
want to do that,
you know?
Yeah.
What have you been working on?
Well,
chuck,
my living room going for his book.
When I'm at work,
sometimes we get pine cones.
Yeah.
So I mean,
to me he seems like hardworking,
pretty demanding.
Um,
but he cares.
I mean,
he's in there trying to,
so the secretary of interior before the
St key,
I had no w I'm like,
what?
I don't even know what that is.
You know,
so that's what,
that's what kind of involvement that
person had in hunter,
in the lives of hunting.
People like me are fishermen.
And so when I didn't even know who it
wasn't,
come to find out her name was sally
jewel,
who was Obama's appointee before trump
appointed zinky.
Um,
so I like the fact that zinc,
he's at shot show.
He's had me out
there.
I'm on this council is at least I have a
seat at the table to say,
and I don't know,
I might get kicked off this council.
I might never get invited back because
I'll ask him,
so what's going on with this?
But right now I have a seat at the
table.
So whatever it's,
it's,
I,
I consider that a win.
At least I can try to find out and
learn.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's an interesting thing because
everything that I've heard about him
that I've read in the media,
uh,
unless I'm reading like a hunting
website or something like that.
Yeah.
Everything I've heard is like that it's
a horror show that he's bringing on all
these trophy hunters and there was an
article equating you would being a,
a trophy hunter and that this council
that he's put together is just this
disgusting sort of justification for
trophy hunting and that they're only
putting it together so that wealthy
people can bring back their elephants
that they shoot in Africa.
Yeah.
Yup.
I've read that too.
I mean,
for me,
and I'm not,
you know,
I've never killed an elephant.
I've never killed a lion,
um,
in every purse.
So even the people on the council that
have,
they do care about animals,
they care.
They're volunteers just like on the
parks advisory board and there they want
to make a positive difference.
You know,
I know every person on that.
I don't know every person personally,
but I know they care about the people of
Africa and that's why they understand
how it works.
They've been there,
they've seen it.
Um,
the guys who I've hunted with,
their personally awesome people,
hardworking people.
Um,
the,
the one guy on my last trip there to
Tanzania,
his daughter was in college and he'd
been a professional hunter over there
for over 20 or 30 years and she was
going to college now getting their
degree.
I mean it's,
explain with a professional hunter over
there is not what we think about it over
here.
When we think of overhear a professional
hunter be a guy hunts.
Oh that's right.
Essentially a guide,
a guide.
They call them Ph is or professional
hunters.
So I mean because of hunting,
he's able to send his,
his daughter to college and I mean,
and now that's gone.
Yeah.
I mean I'm not saying every person,
a lot of them,
a lot of them and they're not getting
any better because right now,
so that policy,
trump said,
well where are we going to review it on
a case by case basis?
So he didn't say,
he didn't say,
okay,
it's legal now everybody can hunt and go
and bring their trophies back.
He said we'll review each one on a case
by case basis.
So that still doesn't make it that good
for hunter because they say,
well,
I'm not going to book a hunt if I don't
know for a fact.
I can bring my trophy back.
Yeah.
So it's not really that much better.
Well,
what you just saying,
that freaks people out.
Like trophy,
like you saying trophy.
It's an animal.
It's an animal's life and you got to
bring it back.
Yeah,
it's that that does,
that distinction is one of the things
that triggers people well,
trophy.
So I mean,
I see heads on your wall right here.
Yeah,
that's a trophy.
But also you ate the meat of that elk.
Oh
yeah.
So I mean it's not like you can't be
both a trophy hunter and hunt for meat
that understand that,
but most people are not blink bringing
back lion meat.
No,
they're not.
Right.
But it's also not mutually exclusive to
be a trophy hunter and eat the meat or
on the elephants.
Those,
none of that meat is going to waste on
an l.
That's true.
That's what it was.
Don't understand their orphans are
actually,
they actually tastes good.
There was a documentary just,
yeah,
I haven't had elephant.
I mean I've had,
I've had crocodile and I've haven't had
lion over there,
but uh,
um,
I had,
that meat is me and the villagers that
live there,
man,
it's,
they,
they need it.
And there was a documentary on CNN
recently called trophy and I remember
there's a scene in there where the
hunter shot an elephant and it wasn't a
big one.
And the people were making fun of him
for shooting.
They're like,
he's this small,
they wanted a big elephant with lots of
meat,
you know?
Okay.
So he,
he got his quote trophy.
They wanted more meat.
So it was like you can have both and
that,
that's,
I'll say trophy hunting because guys
aren't going over there for the meat.
I get it.
I mean,
that's not why you go to Africa,
you're going for the trophy,
but also that the meat isn't going to
waste.
Yeah.
The meat is going to the villagers.
It's not like they're going to let it
rot.
And these people,
I've seen it,
I've seen videos of it.
It's crazy.
They show up with baskets on their head
filled with elephant meet and they're
carrying around like 150 pounds of meat
on their head.
Yeah.
I mean it's really nuts when you've
watched these people just run in and get
chunks of this elephant and they need
it.
It's,
it's really important protein for them.
Yeah.
The solution is very,
very complicated.
Africa is such an enormous place and the
poverty is so intense and the options
are so limited for these people.
There's,
this is not like a simple like ban the
trophy hunting and the animals will live
peacefully in the forest to tweet,
tweet,
bird,
bird.
That's not what's going to happen.
Dies.
Yeah.
It's not just that everything over there
is really complicated.
And I always tell people to watch the
Louis through documentary.
He did a thing on this hunting thing in
Africa and he was over there for a long
time and when he was over there you got
a sense cause he's Louis through is a
really fascinating,
uh,
British documentary guy and you know,
he,
he asked fantastic questions and he's,
he's really polite and he like kind of
pastors them over and over and over
again until it gets to the heart of the
matter.
But at the end of the documentary you
realize like this is complex.
This is not as simple as hey,
these mean people want to go over there
and kill animals and treat them as
objects.
The whole place is kind of,
it's very,
very confused.
Like it's a,
it's a mess.
There's
a,
there's a video right now,
Jamie could probably find it,
but so I think there's three hunters and
they're over there and I can't remember
if they're,
they have bows and arrows or spears,
but what they do,
this lion kills an animal for them to
get meat.
They run in there and chase off the loan
and chase off the lion and steal the
meat.
I seen the cut cut the leg off the,
I can't remember,
it was a will to be as a,
can't remember what it was,
cut the leg off of it and get it out of
there before the lions because lions,
if you run out of lion sometimes they'll
be like,
whoa,
that's weird and I'll back off.
And then before they figured out
there'll be like,
wait a second,
I can kill you.
Then they'll go in that,
in that hesitation time they tried to
cut off that link and get out of there.
So you know when you're here in America
making decisions for people like that,
it's like,
ah,
I got a problem with that.
Yeah.
You will,
you said makes a lot of sense that it's
a first world perspective on a third
world problem where people are literally
starving to death.
Yeah.
They're,
they're trying to figure out how to get,
they need to survive.
They need protein.
That protein is like gold back there.
Yeah.
It's um,
yeah,
this is it.
This is the video and this is on the
discovery channel.
We can't show it,
but these people are running in the
human planet.
If you want to watch it,
I think it's on Netflix or,
okay.
A couple of places.
Yeah,
it's pretty intense.
So the lions,
the lions basically covered with blood.
It's crazy.
I mean they,
the lions just don't know what to do.
They see these people walking out them
with look like weapons and they just
take a chance and bolt.
But what a fucking chance that is.
Yeah.
So they got,
those are bows and arrows.
It looks like these things I know
staring at them and they're super
intense.
What's that video?
It's a title Jamie.
Oh,
stealing.
Stealing meat from lions.
Yeah.
Check it out.
So I mean,
until I,
I don't,
I'm obviously,
not everybody's going to go do this,
but you need to watch us just to get an
idea of how rough it is.
It just,
you know,
the,
the measures I'll take to get some
protein.
Yeah.
I mean,
that whole Cecil,
the lion thing just created this uproar.
If you steal to kill and nobody is hurt,
that's when you can relax.
She says,
Christ.
Yeah.
There,
it goes to feel happy.
He goes with the hindquarter slung over
their shoulders.
Yeah.
And he's carried his family.
And so to me,
you know,
hunters are vilified by a large majority
of the population here was we've said
before nineties 96% of America eats meat
and hunters are the ones out there
getting to themselves.
And like I remember that last buck I
killed,
um,
and Lanai to care.
I was like meticulous on taking care of
that meat.
And as I,
I got it,
the animal,
as I took the bladder out,
I can't remember how what happened,
but like a drop of urine dropped on a
tiny little piece of the Bacchae Ham.
And I was just like,
what?
I was not happy.
And because that meat is,
to me,
it's everything.
It's everything for the hunt.
And I was so disappointed in myself,
but I mean obviously the meat's still
good,
but that I,
I want to be perfect when I'm,
when I'm taking care of it.
Meanwhile,
there's people that eat 96% of people
eat meat and we throw away what's been,
what's been figured.
40% of our food goes in the trash
waste is insane.
This country.
And I think Anthony Bordain just did a
documentary on it,
right?
I don't think it's out yet,
but he did a documentary on food waste.
So
I'm worried about one little tiny piece
of me on an animal I killed and people
who throw away 40% of of what they buy
into the garbage,
they're judging me.
Yeah,
well there's a lot of that out there,
man.
It's,
it's real easy to be negative,
you know?
And that's one thing,
like,
like I said about put up my post about
Lanai.
I just,
the solid or a couple of negative
comments,
I'm like,
am I even reading this stuff?
Like go have at it folks.
Wait,
just walk away.
How did you,
how did you know what they said?
If he didn't read them?
Because I put it up and I saw it
immediately afterwards.
So you read it.
I read like a half a second of it.
But my point is that people will be
negative because it's easy to do.
Cause there are douchebags well they
don't even look,
they're not even thinking it through.
It's like you're fucking just like
killing animals.
People like to just make a statement or
get a reaction or push a button or fuck
with you.
They want,
they want a reaction.
That's all it is.
So you can do one of two things so you
could ignore it.
You can interact with them and argue
with him back and forth.
You could block the comments and all
those things are kind of fucked.
Yeah,
just sucks.
It's uh,
I've,
I've got,
I've been pretty frustrated.
I've whatever,
I'm not going to say I don't read them
cause obviously I read them,
but I get frustrated.
Man.
It's just hunting.
I don't,
people just don't understand hunting
because even hunters will say,
I'll say I don't enjoy the kill and I
don't enjoy the kill.
I enjoy,
um,
getting meat that I can feed my family
myself.
You don't enjoy the kill in that.
It's actually care.
This is awesome.
But it is like,
ah,
it's a relief.
It feels good that your hard work paid
off.
It feels good that all the ethical
consideration that you put into making a
perfect shot is all worked out in the
amount of work that's involved in
making,
you know,
a 70 yard shot,
70 yards,
a long fucking way to hit an animal
perfectly.
And then to have it die in seconds and
then to get that meat,
there's an enjoyment that comes out of,
there's a good feeling,
but it's not like a,
it's not shooting a three pointer at the
buzzer to win the championships and
everybody's jumping up in the air.
It's not,
it's not fun.
People will say,
well,
hunting is killing is fun.
It's like,
it's not fun.
It's not for me.
It's not fun at all.
I,
I killed two bucks,
made two perfect shots.
They went,
um,
not far.
We're down in seconds.
And that was a huge relief to me.
That's why I do what I do every single
day.
And like I said,
I posted on it to be merciful and I
don't enjoy when I'm not as perfect as I
want to be.
And I killed a bull last year in
Colorado.
I was with Johnnie Hamilton,
which,
you know johnny and he was back cow cone
here at this bull,
comes up the hill,
he stops at 15 yards and I hit him
perfect right behind the shoulder.
It perfect.
He ran down,
stopped at 30,
hesitated again.
I already had another arrow on,
boom,
hit him right beside the first show,
first hole.
And I'm like that bull.
I was so convinced he was down and I was
just like,
oh man,
not that.
Felt good.
Got to in him,
perfect through the lungs.
He's going to be done in seconds.
He wasn't done in seconds.
And I have,
I don't know what happened,
um,
it,
whether it was testosterone because he's
coming off the hill,
he's bugling.
He was super fired up so I don't know
what was going on,
but I ended up,
um,
it wasn't as quick and kill is what I
have in my mind.
What a prepare for what I'm happy
accepting.
And that in Johnny knows I wasn't happy.
I was just like,
I was so disappointed.
Um,
I dunno.
Maybe,
maybe 20 minutes,
20 minutes,
something like that.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
How's that possible?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
So tough.
And that's incredible.
Now I w it really bothered me.
It,
it,
uh,
it upset me.
I wasn't,
I was
disappointed with myself.
I was disowned.
There's nothing you could've done
better.
Right.
I don't know.
I don't think you've made a perfect
shot.
I felt like it was perfect,
but you know,
if it's perfect to animals dead and in
10 seconds,
so I don't know.
But when I watched it,
I've killed a lot of bowls.
I've went through the process a lot.
I would take those two shots on any
animal,
any time and feel a hundred percent
confident he was going to go 50 yards.
Um,
this was something that I was really
concerned about when we filmed that
underarmor hunt in,
uh,
Utah.
Yeah.
Cause I was like,
man,
this is going to be on video.
This is,
you know,
it's a,
yeah.
Big Animal.
You know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a big deal.
I want to make sure that this thing that
it's a perfect hit.
Yeah.
You know,
and so the feeling of relief that I got
when I saw that it was a perfect pass
through and that the era that he was
bleeding and po both sides in the exact
spot I wanted to hit and to watch him
wobble way,
like an very unsteady legs walked to
about 20,
30 yards and then tipped over.
Yeah.
That's an amazing of relief.
But
it doesn't feel good.
It doesn't feel good.
It's like,
no,
it's not fun.
Now there's a feeling of like
accomplishment but also of remorse and
they're tied in together.
Yeah.
It's uh,
um,
and for the animal,
like with a bow with a perfect shot,
you know,
on,
on these bucks that I killed,
they didn't know I was there.
So it was just,
I know they didn't feel,
it wasn't like there's a,
a rifle report and bone shattering and
they're dying from trauma.
They're dying from hemorrhage,
like your bowl that in Utah,
that took off his legs were wobbly
because of blood pressure.
He had a blood pressure loss because of
hemorrhage.
That's not painful,
you know?
Um,
and so that's,
that was a perfect scenario.
That's what we prepare for and that's,
that's our goal.
And when it doesn't work like that,
that bothers me.
And so when people chime in on your page
or on my page and these uneducated
comments trying to turn to tell me how I
feel or why I do what I do,
man,
that does not make me happy.
No.
But I understand it's the ability to
comment on things is a very strange
thing because the ability to talk to
people is very different.
It's very difficult to have an audience
to sit in front of someone that,
uh,
you know,
pick a person,
a famous like Morgan Freeman to sit down
across running.
And why pick Morgan Freeman?
It's very hard to,
it's very hard to be in front of him.
Yeah.
To be able to sit down and talk to
someone and to look them in the eyes.
You would choose your words properly and
you'd have a conversation.
But if you just like,
what's on your face,
bro,
like you just,
what's all those black spots on your
face?
You dumb fuck,
you can just put that on twitter and
it's easy.
It's easy.
And that's so it's a human being
communicating with another human being
at saying something insulting and it's
so incredibly easy to do.
It's too,
it's too easy.
We think.
So we don't really understand what we're
doing with that.
And when it comes to hunting,
there's something about the fact that 90
I think it's 97% actually eat,
meet somewhere in the range and maybe 3%
do it themselves.
3% like what do you think it is
nationwide?
If you had to pick nationwide,
like how many people nationwide,
uh,
killed their own food?
Is it even 5%?
Uh,
okay.
Well there's,
I know,
because I looked this up because I was
curious how,
how many people I'm reaching on
instagram?
So there's 13 million licensed hunters.
13 million.
How?
How many isn't there?
300 and some how many people are in
America?
I think it's three 20 is it three 20
somewhere in the range.
320 million.
Yeah.
So what does that under 5%?
It's not a lot.
It's a very small amount.
And how many of them are only eating
that?
How many of them are,
are are spending so much time hunting
that they can live off of the
meat that they kill themselves?
Yeah.
Only now it's one,
maybe 1%.
That's why even I saw people,
like we had the picture of your freezer
back here fold filled with meat and
they're like,
you know,
saying you couldn't eat that.
And I thought you,
you know,
you're just killing what you need to
eat.
But so that's just some big,
those people don't know what the fuck
they're talking about.
I do eat it,
I eat all of it and I'll go through that
whole freezer and a few months and I get
him.
I do a lot of my friends.
That was the key is that I was going to
say is every guest that comes,
you ask if they want game meat and they
take it on the fucking Mooch.
He comes over here constantly is like,
okay,
I need more steak meat.
Well,
have you seen a lot of my friends?
Have you seen his body?
He's neat.
She act monster spot.
Right,
right.
He's a beast.
So I was,
I thought he ate steaks like all day
everyday.
If you ask him,
he'll say he does.
I eat elk quads,
all the,
everything
top to bottom.
But,
uh,
I mean I've,
I give me to wait a lot of my friends
and they love it.
It's like,
it's fucking hard to get off meat.
Where are you going to get it?
I see a lot of people send me messages
that they want to know what this whole
elk meat things about,
so they want to be involved.
They want to know where can I buy elk
because they don't hunt or they want to
start hunting.
But uh,
yeah,
one does.
What we talked about when we loaded up
my dear in your freezer to phrase it is
that,
you know,
hunters,
our providers,
it's a big,
uh,
it feels good to be able to give people
that food.
To me it's,
it's everything.
It's either to feed my family or to give
my friends or not my extended family
meet that I've harvested.
That is,
that's,
to me,
that's as good as it gets.
Yeah.
I had a Michael Hunter in the podcast
recently.
He's the chef that runs that restaurant,
antelope antler in Toronto and they're
getting protested by vegans.
I gave him a bunch of meat and he cooked
it and put it up on instagram.
And then he was like,
this is so awesome.
And it made me feel so good to like look
at these delicious meals with this guy
prepared who's a professional chef with
meat from an animal that I killed.
I give away a lot of that meat,
but I eat it every day.
I eat almost every day.
I eat some sort of game meat.
Yeah.
If I'm home,
that's what I eat.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
we ate,
we ate a bunch in Lanai that as,
what are those sticks call?
Oh,
the uh,
what,
uh,
bob the butcher makes,
he calls him acts as Jax.
Jax.
He makes like a pepperoni.
Yeah.
Like a pepperoni out of a axis.
Deer.
Sensational,
sensational.
He's a really good butcher to like what
he's done with all the cuts and labeled
them all.
And it gives you an envelope that has
all of the recipes of how you should
cook each individual cut.
Yeah.
That's awesome man.
Yeah,
it makes me feel like I never saw any of
this when I was a kid.
I grew up in the city.
I never,
I used to fish,
I used to eat fish that I caught,
but I never was involved in hunting at
all until I was in my forties so when
I,
you know,
I see comments from people that probably
grew up the way I grew up and they don't
get it.
They never,
they're never involved in it,
but yet they're eating meat.
And it's just,
it's because no one's holding them
accountable for what they're saying.
And it,
cause it's easy to say,
oh,
you got a little dirt.
You want it to load.
The animal got a little bit.
It's so common.
So Domino's,
imagine if that's what it meant.
Like if you have a little,
if you have a little deck,
you just want to go out and kill,
it would be a lot of death out there.
It's a lot of the little dicks and
Shell.
I'm just to prove her wrong.
Hey,
let's look at that.
A bear attack.
The poor bastard.
I forgot to do that.
Well,
that was one of the weird things that we
were talking about.
How warning graphic content man mauled
by a bear while taking a selfie with it.
Go full screaming this please.
God is stupid.
Fuck.
So this bear apparently was injured and
this dumb ass in India decided he was
going to go and take a selfie with it.
Oh,
in hitting it.
you stupid.
Fuck.
I don't know.
Oh No,
it's got the guy.
That's why.
Oh it does.
Yeah.
They're hitting it because it's got the
guy.
He's already fucking this guy up.
So that's a bear in India.
Yeah,
they have barris.
Oh,
look at it.
Oh Jesus Christ.
That's not good.
No,
that's,
he's almost free.
Look that guys get Shitty Jujitsu.
We'll just got to do.
Oh,
see,
look at that right there.
You're free,
Bro.
You're free.
Oh,
it's tearing his hand depart as you got
to shut this off at dogs.
Dogs like work,
bark,
bark.
Oh man,
that's,
yeah.
It's a shit way to go,
folks.
God,
that looks terrible.
Why did no one have a fucking gun?
Does no one have a knife?
Does no one have a baseball bat and go
clunk,
that fucking thing.
And the head.
Nobody's doing anything.
Yeah.
They're like,
it's over.
We've lost him.
Wow.
Yeah.
Is that the bear
or the bear?
Is that what it says?
I don't know why they would show it
afterwards.
Just as water burger looks like.
Yeah.
That's what,
just some stupid video of a bear in a
zoo.
Yeah.
Um,
bad,
bad to take pictures of bears.
It's a real common thing in yellowstone.
They have real issue with that.
But people would try and get real close
to bears,
take selfies with them.
I've done that before.
Well,
I think it's different.
You've done it.
Why?
While bear hunting.
Yeah.
But you've only done it with black
bears.
Yeah.
Like you'd never turn your back on
grizzly like down.
No,
no,
no.
But in black bear it's still still not
saved.
I can say a smart at all.
It's definitely not.
Um,
yeah,
but it's,
uh,
you know,
you can read bears.
Bears have a personality or attitude
just like dogs.
Yeah.
And so it's a,
if there's an aggressive bear coming in,
probably not going to turn my back and
yeah.
I have one dog that I will let my kids
do.
My massive,
my kids could ride that dog.
They can do anything.
That dog is a loving dog.
He loves everybody.
Yeah.
You know,
and then I have another dog that's a
Shibu Ino bulldog.
I don't let anybody fuck with him.
Yeah.
He's the littlest dog too.
He's an asshole.
Like if you like try to get them to get
up and get out of the house in the
morning,
he'll growl at you.
You're like,
listen motherfucker,
come on.
We'll go outside.
Yeah.
It's taught her well.
Are you ground bitch?
I'm like,
come on man.
Fatty for 14 years.
Get up,
go out.
He's just old and it's,
he's in pain a lot is,
um,
it's really hard for him to get up.
But the point is,
the other dog,
I'm sure he's old too,
but he just,
he's a sweetheart.
He's got no aggression in him towards
people.
He's just a sweet,
sweet dog.
That's just personalities.
Bears are just like,
that is some bears that are cunts.
Yeah.
There's actually,
there's a petition out there about,
um,
band or,
I don't know,
something about me,
but it says I took a Selfie of a bear
then killed it,
which is false.
The bearer took a selfie of I did not
kill because it wasn't old enough.
Yeah.
So just to dispel any rumors,
those petitions are fascinating.
You know,
I mean,
people don't want you to kill bears.
Here's the thing,
people don't,
they don't want animals to die.
They don't want you to kill animals.
How do you feel about animals killing
animals?
Because if you don't want animals to
die,
one of the best ways to stop that is to
kill bears.
Yeah.
But if you kill bears,
they get more angry at you for killing
bears,
mountain lions and lions than anything
else.
Maybe elephants,
which don't kill anything.
Total herb herbivores.
They kill people.
Elephants do occasionally.
Mostly when people do something stupid
like fuck with them.
It's not,
they don't go out of their way to kill
people.
I think they do.
I doubt it.
I changed me this,
I think they kill people if people are
just where they want to go and like,
hey asshole,
that's killing them.
How about you get away from the
elephant,
but you know the,
the problem with that is like if you
grow in crops,
like we were saying,
and then the elephant starts eating your
crops,
you like get Outta here.
And the elephants like,
oh,
excuse me.
Yeah.
Stomp.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a wrap kid.
Elephants can be aggressive.
They can,
but they're also fucked with constantly.
And you know,
there's just something to me,
I like elephants.
Yeah.
I think they'll ever,
they look awesome.
They're cool.
I'm glad they're,
they're real.
I know they're smart.
I know they have like tight bonds in
their community and you don't have to
kill one of those to eat it.
I mean,
it's like there's plenty of other
animals to eat is I just,
but if I was starving to death and I was
living in a place that only had
elephants,
for sure I'd kill an elephant.
Yeah.
I mean,
if that was all I had to eat,
our friend Brian Stevens said it tasted
delicious.
He said he ate one in Africa,
did it,
and he said it was a,
is one of the most delicious steaks he's
ever had in his life.
And I was like,
what?
Like how is that possible?
Endangered Elephants and tigers kill a
human.
One human a day in India is growing
population squeezes habitat.
Yeah.
But this is a crazy situation,
man.
India's fucking so overpopulated.
It is a very,
very small place.
What is he doing trying to get over that
fence?
So
that tearing apart that car,
like any human deaths since 2014 wow.
So they kill people.
1,000 human deaths in four years,
whilst tigers have killed 92 people in
the same period.
So elephants kill Weymar.
Whoa.
That's nuts.
At the end of that bear selfie thing,
it said to other people were killed in
that state in India,
and they were both trying to take
selfies with elephants.
Fucking dip shits.
One was a kid.
There's too many people in India.
I mean,
India is grossly overpopulated.
India,
I think is smarter than the United
States.
Right?
Isn't it?
Like what size is India?
I Dunno.
I think it's smaller than the contiguous
United States,
but it has a billion people in it.
Yeah.
It's slightly more than one third.
The size.
Oh,
more than one third.
The size.
Okay.
1 billion is a lot.
Yeah.
That's a lot of fucking people.
Triple a we have.
And the third the size.
Yeah.
No third larger.
Oh,
that's what you're saying,
right?
It says it's slightly more than one
third.
The size of the USO
third our size.
I thought you were saying a third
larger.
What I thought I was saying too,
but I just,
I reread it and it,
oh,
that makes sense.
A third of us,
but has three times of people foc.
It's half the size of Russia.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
I killed.
That's crazy.
How do you fix appellees?
You know?
Yeah.
That's the best part of,
um,
I don't know.
There's Africa is some places in Africa
also.
They,
I know that because uh,
malaria medicine is good.
People aren't dying from AIDS.
There's a lot of pee.
Oh,
that's how big is India compared to the
USA?
Look at this.
India fits right in there.
My favorite is how big is Africa go to?
How big is Africa?
Because Africa is hilarious.
Like that.
USA,
India,
China,
Eastern Europe,
Germany,
France,
Spain,
Italy,
Switzerland,
Netherlands,
Belgium,
Portugal and Japan and Great Britain all
fit inside of Africa.
Fuck,
that's big.
Yeah,
it's big area.
Fuck yeah.
That is crazy.
Africa is amazing though,
man.
That's crazy.
When you look at that on a map,
you can be like,
oh wow.
Yeah.
The Congo is as wide as America is.
Just the Congo,
the true size of Africa,
man.
So when out and someone says like
elephants are endangered in Africa in
some spots,
some spots they're overrun.
It's just like,
yeah,
grizzlies are endangered in La.
They are really endangered in La.
Unless you go to these certain bars in
Santa Monica Boulevard,
there's for days.
Um,
now I,
you know,
I didn't know that was a gay reference
until recently.
We've been hanging out with not gay
people.
I guess you don't hang around.
You just,
you got to have this read.
Oh,
read on these.
You don't have to hang out.
You don't have to hang out with them.
You don't have to actually go there.
Like,
I need to know guys about k.
Well,
take your pants down first.
You want to get shot?
Uh,
Hey,
speaking of,
I dunno what we're speaking of,
but we need to talk about Kanye.
Just oh,
Jamie's got crazy.
Kanye conspiracy theories.
Slash.
Theories.
Well,
first,
so first of all,
he's like,
he came out for trump recently,
sort of,
he wore a make America great again hat
on,
but he also called trump a bald thief.
Why suddenly too?
He did.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
he called them balled.
Crooker appalled.
Connie Aa is a lunatic.
Yeah.
So I could care less what he says about
him.
He loves saying,
Jamie Sleeps with a picture of Cognac.
I'll stop if you believe that shit to
believe that people believe everything
you saying about me.
It's not a,
it's a,
it's a pendant with a picture with his
picture on in it.
Jamie's is a big fan of two things.
Nuclear Weapons and trump.
He's,
yeah,
he loves nuclear bombs and he loves
physics class.
Yeah,
so trump,
here's,
here's what I like.
I,
well Connie is a lunatic,
but I do like candace owens who was also
new on the scene in my Fox News world.
You love that.
I Love,
love conservatives and candice is just
like,
she walked in from work the other day
and I was like,
I started listening to Fox News is I
don't,
of course I'm watching.
I'm like,
who the hell is this?
You Say Fox News is on of course,
because Fox News just blaring propaganda
through your house all the time.
Do you ever switch it up?
Like have like CNN on the back,
nine Fox News on in the living room.
I watch it all.
I do watch CNN.
Alex Jones says 200 1:30 PM to watch him
for wars exclusive on Canyon.
Candice and Kanye got exclusive.
I don't,
it doesn't happen every year.
It's like alive.
What is he going to say?
Featuring candice and Kanye.
So you get a lump them in together,
but he talking about them,
everyone thought they weren't going to
be on this show today.
Oh,
it didn't happen for wars exclusive.
He probably called them Kanye.
It's Alex Jones.
I could care less that Connie says.
I like what canvas says.
Well Jamie thinks that all this
wackiness with candace owens and Kanye
is really Kanye just getting people
hyped up about the release of his new
album,
which will be out in a few months.
So he's getting people fired up.
You think that's what's happening Jamie?
Yeah,
there's a internet conspiracy that's
been like,
not proven because it can't be proven
yet,
but uh,
there's a long twitter thread and a few
like reports now blogs or magazines if
you will,
that sort of lead to like an Andy
Kaufman esque type performance art piece
that he's doing.
Maybe bring up a conversation about some
of these topics he's actually talking
about.
Or maybe we'll find out when his album
comes out.
It's Kanye is doing performance art.
Then what's the point?
Here's the Po,
here's the problem is there's a certain
amount of him that is undeniably insane
and um,
you've seen that,
like that thing that Jimmy Kimmel mocked
where you had that little kid.
He used to do little kids saying things
that Kanye said and like he would have
like,
yeah,
like he would have little kids say it
exactly.
By the way,
hate him.
He's a nice guy.
No,
you met her.
Be like him.
I like it a lot.
I wouldn't,
he's like,
why he cries about hunting.
What did he cry about?
Lions.
Sea Salt.
Yeah.
I don't know why.
Maybe some medication.
Sometimes guys take things and it ups
their estrogen and they just get real
watery.
Yeah.
That cry went to be able to do really
well that I feel like a bitch sometimes.
I cried when conor mcgregor was talking
about the support he gets from Ireland.
I had to hold back the tears.
Did you being honest?
I was paying honest.
I was interviewing him and he started
talking about the love I get from these
people from Ireland.
Like,
God,
that must be amazing.
That actually,
yeah,
no,
I get that.
That's different than Jimmy though.
Crying like drumming up stupid stuff for
Cecil the lion.
The lion thing is weird.
Why don't think it's weird?
You know,
there was a great article that was in
the New York Times in Zimbabwe.
We don't cry for lions,
right?
It happened right after that.
Yeah.
This guy was talking about his family
members that were killed by lions.
We have a very idealistic view of what a
lion is,
and I'm a big fan of lions.
I'd love that.
They're real.
I love that they exist.
I love that you can see videos of them.
One of my favorite documentaries of all
time is it documented called relentless
enemies and it's about these,
this one pack of lions that got a river
changed its path and they got stranded
on an island and there's one pack of,
I of lions grew enormous because all
they have to hunt is water buffalo.
So instead of this variety of different
game animals,
all they have to hunt as these huge 2000
pound animals.
So they grew jacked like hulk size lines
where the female lions or as big as a
regular mail.
Really,
it's all fucking amazing document.
See if he could find some images from
it.
The way they look is just tracked.
There's so muscular,
they're fucking huge.
Like female lions,
600 lbs.
Wow.
Fucking amazing.
But the documentary is incredible
because these water buffalo are so big
and so hard to take out.
They need like,
oh,
it's Cape Buffalo,
so they need like six or seven of them
just jump Oh fucking buffalo and drag
him to the ground.
Those things are solid muscle too.
Yeah.
Buffalo.
Yeah,
they're giant.
But because of,
and this,
I believe this is over the period,
I think it's a short amount of time.
Yes.
And short amount of time that these
lions have lived on this one island,
but they did it.
A whole documentary about it.
Well,
as all this on this island or hyenas,
Cape Buffalo
and lions and a few birds and
[inaudible].
There's nothing else.
When they're neat,
they don't want to eat hyenas.
Yeah.
Mad.
You want a hyena steak tastes like awful
one or would it taste like awful?
Today's great.
Imagine pigs.
You look at a pig,
like how could that tastes good?
Yeah,
I guess,
I don't know.
Wild pig is fucking delicious.
And they looked disgusting in Africa.
They say hyenas are a witches witches.
Let's see.
Margaret,
they're laughing at you.
Yeah.
And then that was a,
that was a whole thing.
It's like a,
an Alpha female has a Dick Remember
that?
It's not cool.
No,
it's bigger than anything else.
So Jimmy Kimmel also made the small
penis reference about hunters.
What does this Okavango Delta Lions from
planet Earth to?
Yeah.
You can't really tell him that picture.
See,
go do,
um,
Google,
uh,
enormous lions.
Relentless enemies.
Closest I could get,
I know there's video on it.
You can get some planet or two or that
its enemies doc,
I can't show that.
Right,
right,
right.
But this is planet earth too,
but the,
the documentary is just,
just google,
relentless enemies.
Documentary.
Wait.
So this is this area where the lions are
stranded in this one particular,
and it's not a very large spot,
but in this one place.
Yeah,
there it is.
It's really fucking awesome now.
Oh yeah.
Don't,
don't,
don't see if they get some good images
of how big these things are.
You can't really tell.
They just looked very,
oh,
ela and watching sex while watching a
bank go to the second one.
Not that one,
but go back to the,
uh,
that page.
They go to the second one.
Relentless enemy's lines in buffalo.
This is the one.
So this is,
so this is the,
the actual documentary.
And there's also a pride of lions that
are regular size on this island too,
which is really confusing to biologists.
They're like,
well,
what the fuck?
Can't really tell here.
Yeah.
But see how jack these females are.
It's tough to tell here,
but here they're trying to take out this
Cape Buffalo out.
Look at this.
This is crazy.
They're all piling on it.
Yeah.
The females are much,
much larger than a regular female.
Pretty brutal.
Amen.
Evolution.
It's fascinating.
Shed watching things struggled to
survive
hard out there for a pimp.
Death has never pretty.
No,
but it being the thing is people would
have a really hard time if a person was
doing any of the things that lions too.
I mean,
you would think that would be awful,
but do you have a hard time with lions
doing the things at lines,
do you say?
No,
because that's natural.
Okay.
Well do you realize that the only reason
why people even exist is because people
did.
When lions do the differences,
humans have compassion.
So I mean,
um,
animals,
there's no,
they don't have time for compassion out
there.
You know what I mean?
It's a nonexistent,
the concept,
I put up this video on my instagram,
the zebra had just,
the zebra full had just been dropped.
Um,
it was just barely standing wobbly legs.
This lion,
big male lion walks up to it.
Kills it.
Like it had been alive minutes.
I saw that video.
That's life.
That bum.
Yeah,
but not as much as the one where you,
you had,
was it a moose calf or an elk cap?
Kath.
Yeah,
eating it alive and it's screaming out
and it's mother's just a few feet away
trying to figure out what to do.
And that grizzlies just tearing it
apart.
That sucked.
But that's what they do.
If you don't control the populations of
grizzlies,
that happens all the time.
And even today,
right now with the,
just the populations as they exist right
now in places like Alberta,
they estimate that 50% of all moose,
elk and deer calves are killed or fonts
or killed by bears.
They just,
they just tear them apart.
Yeah.
Half of them.
And that's,
that's what happened up in British
Columbia because they did that.
They did a vote in Vancouver essentially
to vote on whether grizzly hunting
should be allowed.
Of course,
people in the city,
you know,
just like here,
don't think there are hardly any
grizzlies left.
So they said no.
And so the,
the new,
um,
I can't remember what the political
parties called,
but the one in control now said grizzly
hunting is no longer socially
acceptable.
And so they can't hunt them.
And you'll see what's going to happen
with the,
with the other animals.
They're going to have to hunt them,
but they're gonna hire people to hunt
them.
What happens in those situations is what
happens in California when it comes to
mountain lions and they still get
hunted,
but they get hunted in a very hush,
hush way higher assassins to go after
these lines.
It kill dogs and cats and you know,
scare the shit out of joggers and that's
what they're going to have to do to
bears.
The problem with that hunt vote was the
way it was explained,
Gritty Bowman did a podcast about it and
what they were explaining was that it
was a very small percentage of people
that even voted on this.
Yeah,
I mean it was like it just a few
thousand people voted on it and most
people were unaware of the consequences
that there needs to be a balance of
these bears and these animals.
Otherwise the animals are going to get
decimated in the bears getting
encroached on human populations.
And then on top of that,
these bears like that.
The,
there's been this whole business of
guiding and outfitting for these bears
and the biologists are not talking to
the people that are actually in the
woods on the ground,
but that the population numbers,
if you talk to people like my friend
Mike Cochran who lives up there,
he's,
he'll tell you there's a lot of bears.
There's a large population of grizzly
bears and it's very difficult to
determine what the actual population is
if they're not listening to the people
that are on the ground every day.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
you gotta,
you gotta listen to the people that are
boots on the ground,
the in when you have a vote on something
like this,
no one's taken into consideration these
things.
Like you're just going bears,
why would you kill a bear?
They're amazing.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
I love,
I love bears.
The anthropomorphization of animals is
one of the more dangerous things that
people have done with civilization where
we've decided that animals are like us.
They're our friends.
They have,
they wear baseball hats and fucking
ties.
God.
It's just weird and we do it from the
time kids are little,
you know,
you give him a teddy bear and then you
know,
you tell them,
oh,
you don't kill real bears.
Do you like real bears are going to kill
you?
Do you understand what a bear is?
Yeah,
like a bear is that thing with that guy
in India.
That's it there.
It's a monster.
I mean,
it's an awesome monster.
I'm glad they're real.
Yeah,
me too.
But their meat is delicious.
It is nuts.
The other thing,
it's like people think that somehow now
that you can't eat bears,
like people get mad at you for killing a
bear,
but they won't get mad at you for
killing a pig because pigs are ugly.
Like a wild,
like wild pigs or the one of those one
animals were vegans and animal rights
activists don't have an answer to.
Right.
You know,
they really,
they don't like seeing people shooting
them out of helicopters.
They don't like seeing people hunting
them.
But if you looked at the actual numbers,
I would love to sit down,
have someone from Peta or any animal
rights activist group sit down with
someone who really understands the wild
pig infestation problem that the
invasive species that doesn't have a
natural Predator that breeds three to
four times a year and can have as many
as six to eight pigletts and it's the
litter and they're just s just fucking
like there's no tomorrow and they're
having tons of them and they just
destroyed billions of dollars in crops
every year.
What do you do about that?
What are you gonna do?
Tell me what to do animal right?
People tell him they don't think about
it because this is not an a balanced,
nuanced objective approach.
They haven't looked at this whole thing.
What they've decided is that killing
[inaudible] beans is bad.
Speciesism is bad.
You know that one?
Speciesism here's a specie.
I'm a speciesist God.
Everybody is.
When it comes to bugs,
how fact everybody is at subway.
Hey,
you want some bacon on that?
Yeah.
Throw some bacon on there,
but if you don't,
if that's,
if you eat at subway,
bro,
these niggas don't eat.
It's everybody doesn't need it.
Subway vegans don't eat at subway vegans
at what?
3%?
Yeah.
What is it?
The number of Vegans,
what's the percentage?
3% what is it?
What's the percentage of vegans that are
cont?
Not that all of a sudden her hundred.
I said a hundred but not,
not Wesley town.
No,
I know a lot of cool vegans.
Yeah,
me too.
Ian Edwards Outright Enid was just one
of my best friends.
He's a big,
he's a Vegan,
so there's two.
Yeah,
I know.
I know a lot of cool vegans,
but there's a lot of vegans that are
just super self righteous.
Like once the,
once they're on that team,
they're super self righteous.
Yeah.
And ask him how much time they have in
the woods.
Yeah.
How much time you have around bears,
how much time you have.
Yeah.
Got a lot of time in the woods to form
that opinion.
Oh,
do you really understand?
Yeah.
Come across a bear.
Tear it apart.
A P a cub or a killing?
A calf elk.
Oh,
you know,
I mean constantly.
I don't even,
when I put that up,
I don't even like to watch it.
I'm a hunter.
I've killed a lot of animals.
I don't like to watch it,
but we have to show it.
Yeah.
How do you think they feel about animals
killing animals?
Do you think they feel it's okay because
it's natural?
I don't know what they think,
but wonder if it's just a convenient
thing that they just look past la,
la,
la.
I think that's probably mostly what it
is.
Yeah,
because if they really did want to see
like what is more beautiful?
Well that's objective more.
It's what's more beautiful.
A deer.
A bear.
I don't know,
but I do know that one doesn't eat the
other deers don't eat bears,
you know?
So it feels like if you,
yeah.
If you felt like they were both equally
beautiful,
you'd want to protect the deer from the
bear.
[inaudible] man,
I dunno.
I know.
As a hunter I people always ask me,
well,
what do you enjoy hunting them out?
It's what our,
I'm hunting.
I mean I'm,
I,
I respect and I'm drawn to all that.
I like being close to all the animals.
So it's,
uh,
it's,
I don't really,
I can't have a hard time writing them
personally.
Well for me,
um,
I just like the ones that are delicious
and they're all pretty delicious.
They also that we hunt.
Yeah,
they had the variety of it.
I just liked the fact too that I'm not
getting meat from some fucking factory
farm.
The people that are getting meat from
the store and from Burger King and then
are still shitting on hunters and
saying,
you got a little Dick.
Like you're being silly.
You're being silly now.
I know,
but I'm getting,
so we've talked about this every single
time,
but the number of people reaching out is
growing exponentially daily on who wants
to be a hunter,
who wants to provide for themselves and
their family and really sees the draw to
that.
And that is,
it's the natural way.
It's,
it's a every day,
every week.
So the concern people have in the raw
real good concern for getting food that
hasn't been tainted with antibiotics and
hormones.
Yeah.
Getting natural food.
There's no more natural organic food
than an animal that is literally living
in the wild until you take it out.
Like they don't even know you're there
until that Arrow hits some of the most
perfect life up until that time
generally.
And it's,
um,
it's the,
it's a way it's meant to be really.
It's,
you know,
humans have hunted up until very
recently.
That's for,
for most of our existence,
Kanye hunting,
if you just,
it,
you take anybody hunting.
What'd you take?
Kanye,
what would you take him bear hunting?
I'd take him.
Bear bear is good because,
you know,
it's like,
um,
when we bet your first bow hunt was
bear,
just because it's,
it's pretty controlled.
There's a lot of bear.
Um,
you can go on some of these hunts and if
you went on an axis,
deer hunt for your first hunt would
quit.
That's tough.
So with bear,
I think it's a good first time and then
I can,
I like being able to explain why we're
bear hunting the bear we're looking for.
We're looking for the big old mail.
Here's how you identify it.
I like being right there.
So if,
if I took Kanye hunt hunting,
it would be bear hunting.
Hmm.
Um,
do you think he would be able to do it?
I don't know him.
I mean he's,
he seems crazy,
but I dunno,
it's Connie out there.
Bear hunting just bought like 300 acres
in Wyoming,
so maybe he did.
He and Connie,
you bought 300 acres in Wyoming.
He's probably going to build a sneaker
factory out there.
That's a good looking country right
there.
That's gorgeous.
No.
Why did he buy 300 acres in Wyoming?
That's where he's filming our finishing
his album right now.
I think he filmed or recorded part of
it.
I would go with the album again.
It's all I'm telling you,
it's all fine.
It work for Kanye.
Tell him the truth.
Jimmy.
Jimmy's got a side job.
I mean,
he's also apparently building in the
interview he talks about,
I think he's building some houses or
something out there to,
wow.
You imagined Kim Kardashians wandering
around Wyoming.
Oh,
that's when people are going to really
want to get rid of the bear population
cause why am he's got some fucking
grizzlies.
Imagine it's the big grizzly bears take
out the Kardashians.
Well I think,
you know,
I think people like she's,
I laugh and Jamie,
that's terrible.
That would,
hey,
thank you about Wyoming.
Like goofy stupid.
Like that's good.
But he's in Wyoming.
Thank you.
About the album sales go crazy.
Yeah.
So yeah,
if you like covered her would be fat and
fun horror movie.
Send her out there in the woods.
I think people like Kanye and I don't
know about Kim or,
uh,
but man,
archery is a discipline people need.
So I mean they need some discipline.
I think archery can be,
it can be powerful.
You know,
I had sent you that quote I think
yesterday about,
there's like a,
there's things you do in your life or
theirs before you did them.
And after he did them and there was a
definitive line right there.
I think archery can be aligned like that
where everything was before and now
everything after and it's that powerful.
Well,
I think difficult things are important
for people to do.
You know?
I mean,
I think challenges are extremely
important.
If you don't have a challenge and you're
like the human mind,
you know,
we were talking about idle time being
the devil's playground,
right?
If the human mind needs challenges,
you need something that's stimulating
and intriguing to you and bow hunting is
insanely difficult.
Archery,
forget about bow hunting.
You've,
you just want to eat vegetables all day.
Archery is insanely difficult.
It's,
and it's something that requires
concentration on all these different
levels,
like mental concentration.
You have to focus on your
posture and your form and make sure that
everything's right and timing the
release of this shot is right.
All that stuff requires so much of your
focus and so much thought that it cleans
your mind.
Yeah.
It cleans your mind of all these other
things,
all the bullshit and the life stress
goes away when that Arrow flies through
the air and shoot hits that Bullseye.
Like it feels amazing.
That's,
that's one I had a lot of respect for.
Uh,
Ryan Zinky when I went back there to DC
because I took them with a bow back
there and there's a huge group of people
standing around.
He's shooting an Arrow at a small target
in a gymnasium.
And you know,
I mean,
you're putting,
you're putting yourself out there
because there's no guarantee you're
going to be very good with a bow.
Well,
he's doesn't have experience with it,
right?
No,
no,
not,
especially now with that bow,
I think he shot one at the western
hunting expo,
but I saw him shooting in the air.
Like the,
the Arrow was lined up like you're
shooting,
you know,
down schools.
I instead of with a site,
that's how they used to do it.
Right.
Like a lot of,
like,
I saw some old pictures of Ted nugent.
He used to shoot a compound bow,
the release with without a release.
Oh without,
well I don't know if he used a release,
but I know that he didn't have a site.
Right.
And he was like looking down the,
the shaft of the Arrow like a guy would
do with a recurve bow.
Yeah,
look,
well that's not,
that's,
that's in a good position.
Maybe that,
that one right there so that,
that's a little more,
yeah.
Well that's it.
That's a comp.
Well that's a recurve I think,
isn't it?
It's hard to tell cause you only looking
at the top of the riser.
But what is,
is that a recurve or comp?
And I can't tell,
but it says that,
yeah,
Ted nugent is an irresponsible idiot.
Look,
Jamie,
why'd you hold silicone cowboys blog?
Uh,
well he's also got the boat canted
sideways.
Too.
Scared.
Yeah,
that's sorta how you do that.
Yeah.
See like there,
well that's a,
he,
he's got no side on his boat.
He's just looking down the arrow.
So that's how he used to hunt.
Yeah.
He used to shoot with a tiny little
stabilizer,
no site and shoot instinctive.
And they switched it up a few years back
and started shooting with sorry sites,
but you know,
but so anyway,
so uh,
Zinky was there,
put himself out there and yeah,
if you like hit the floor and it
ricocheted off in the crowd,
mean somebody in the eye.
Right.
And so I respected that,
you know,
you take,
you're taking a chance and I just think
that that stuff like that is good for
people.
So,
you know,
Kanye included,
man,
if you want to shoot a few arrows and
kill a bear,
I'll go.
He doesn't have time for that man.
He's revolutionizing fashion.
He's going to get,
you had to wear dresses.
Men are going to wear dresses because of
Konya.
That's what Jamie was telling me.
Yeah,
Connie's going to start wearing dresses
and then other people are going to join
in and he's selling flip flops and the
bottom looked like mountain boots.
Slides slide.
What is this all true?
The dresses.
If you want to have your finger on the
pulse of what's going on today with the
kids,
you got to talk to young Jamie Vernon.
God,
that's amazing.
He's,
he's my goto liaison for what the fuck
these kids are up to.
Yeah.
I'm a 50 year old man.
I don't know what the fuck's happening.
It's hard to pay attention to.
It's hard to pay attention to
everything.
That's for sure.
I go to young Jamie.
Yeah,
that's true.
I'm busy.
I can't,
I can't keep up with everything.
Well at plus you're off social media
now,
while I'm not often,
I posted twice today by bucketing the
flip phone instead.
No,
no.
I have discipline.
I'm not like Ari should fear.
You heard me,
Ari,
he's got no fucking discipline.
Is that right?
Yeah.
I mean he talks about it.
He's lucky if he gets his phone in his
hand like he's like,
I can't.
He goes,
I'll be late for everything.
I'll be like 20 minutes late.
I just,
I sit down and I can't get off.
He goes,
I'm powerless.
Like,
wow,
that's crazy.
I don't get that.
That's not good,
but I do know that not thinking about
that stuff for three days made me feel
better.
It's like a cleanse.
I think ultimately there's a,
there's a tremendous amount of pressure
and being in the public eye,
whether you're in the public eye,
on social media or public eye doing a
podcast or anything like that.
So for me,
doing nothing but bow hunting for six
days like was a,
it was a very difficult release yeah.
In that difficult,
in a difficult task and not difficult.
Like,
uh,
I needed to go back to it quickly.
Difficult in that like bow hunting is
hard to do.
So in doing that thing and concentrating
on that thing only,
I wasn't thinking at all about like
twitter or you weren't distracted by
stupid shit,
the news.
No,
what I liked that last day,
it was,
uh,
um,
I loved,
let's see.
So I killed a buck earlier in the day.
Um,
you guys had been on some stocks,
you came,
drove down,
loaded the buck up,
took it to Bob,
the butcher,
and then we're,
so it was,
I think later in the morning,
normally when it'd be like,
okay,
let's go get something to eat.
We'll regroup and come back in the
afternoon.
But you're like,
no,
I want to keep hunting.
You know,
you were just so tunnel vision focused
on hunting and it was so,
I was like,
I was so excited.
So we were out there and it was getting
hot by this time and we're just finding
deer glassing dear putting together
these stocks.
And uh,
it was just like,
it was seriously one of
sounds stupid,
I would say the best day of my life.
But I mean,
that's a perfect day for me.
It was fun.
It was,
it was,
you guys went down on that stock,
you and Alec and,
and I found that that bedded buck by
himself,
the wide bug,
and it was just like,
man,
what a great day.
It was an awesome day and that's how I
would've done it if my family wasn't
there.
I would have just been doing it all.
Yeah.
I wanted to come back.
I would have just brought some snacks
and water and stayed out.
Yeah.
I'm just one of their to do,
you know,
and it's,
like I said,
it's,
it's like a cleanse.
Yeah.
There's something about the difficulty
of it,
especially when I was doing it by
myself.
There was a time for a while where I was
stocking on this buck by myself without
Alec,
without anybody.
And like this is like,
it's,
it's such a singular focus.
You thinking about one thing,
you just checking the,
when checking your range,
trying to close it on.
I'm putting bushes in between you and
him so he can't see you creep in trying
to,
and it's,
there's something about that that's so,
it's so primal.
It just resonates with your DNA.
There's something about it where like
you get,
if you get one of those animals and then
as you're eating it,
you're going to remember that moment
forever.
You gotta remember.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's not just like getting something
from a restaurant or from the grocery
store.
It's getting,
you're eating's I've got an action.
You have a massive connection to it.
Yeah.
And that's,
I,
I videoed a little bit on that deer I
killed that day and I put it on my
instagram story,
just little clips about where I was,
where the buck was kind of the,
the strategy taken off my boots and all
that.
And so many people sent messages saying
that that was fascinating.
And I'm like,
man,
does,
I mean,
how long does the instagram stories stay
up?
No,
but I saved it on the highlights.
Oh,
that when you saved.
So is it listed under,
it says access stock.
Oh,
that's bad house.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's,
people can check it out and it's just
like,
I was reading the comments and seeing
and reading the messages and people
saying how fascinating it was and it,
how educational and I'm like,
on one hand I'm like,
that's awesome.
On another hand,
it made me feel bad for him because
that's just,
I've done that so many times.
And it is,
it's,
it's powerful and it's,
it feels like the way it should be.
But I feel bad for people who haven't
experienced that.
So I feel good for you.
Now that you're in that and that,
but the people sending you messages,
I,
I'm like,
I would love to almost be able to share
that with them somehow or,
or I mean that's as good as I can do
right now.
That's one of the hardest things for
people's to get in it to get started.
Yeah.
Cause it's like the learning curve.
That's what I was gonna ask you is,
uh,
he had been bow hunting now.
What was that first bow hunt we went on?
What year was that?
2013 or 1414 so four years,
something like that.
Yeah.
So for years and it's a,
I dunno,
it's what,
what,
what's changed from that first year to
this year for you?
I mean
experience for sure.
Yeah.
Having more hunts under my belt,
understanding how little I really know.
It's like one of those things.
There's a,
there's a great expression I think from
Dennis Mckenna that once the,
the bonfire of understanding
grows,
the surface area of ignorance is
revealed is that the bigger the bonfire,
the more you realize,
like the more you understand,
the more you realize how much there is
to learn.
That's one of the things about hunting
with each experience,
especially something like Lanai,
which is so it's so difficult.
It's like the most difficult.
But I mean at least what I've
experienced in my short amount of time
doing it,
the most difficult kind of hunting spot
and stocking things that are just
fucking wired,
super pressured.
The stock is the most difficult.
The,
I mean if you,
if you have to backpack in the
mountains.
Yeah.
That's a different kind of vessel.
Different kinds.
Yeah.
The stock of these and getting a bow
range and making the shot.
Yeah,
that's,
yeah.
It's almost as hard as it gets on the
animals that I've hunted.
There's some antelope in Africa that are
just as quick,
but um,
backpack hunting's probably the hardest
physically.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
I mean there's,
that's a whole different challenge and a
whole different knowledge base that
you'd have to delve into,
but as far as stocking and getting those
killed with the bow,
these access,
dear,
you're right.
Also like I would imagine that backpack
hunting in the mountains is also more
mentally taxing because you can't just
go back to the cabin.
You can't just go back to the lodge.
You're out there in a tent and you're 20
miles in and if you break your ankle,
you're going to die.
Yeah,
Yup.
Oh,
you're going to have to take that thing
up and crawl out of there.
It's a little better now because people
have way more access than when I started
when I,
there was this,
you'd have to get to the top of the
mountain,
even get barely cell phone service if
that was even possible,
but now you know,
there's a lot of light phones.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
A lot of people have access to which,
which is nice,
but still it's,
it's a,
it's intimidating for a lot of people.
Yeah.
The barrier for entry is very high.
It's very hard to get started.
And I'm just really lucky that I got
started because of a podcast that I got
to meet Rinella and got into hunting and
then got to meet you and then got into
archery and bow hunting and all that
stuff.
And,
but it's for someone on the outside
that's looking in,
it's extremely difficult now.
But here's what you do.
You go to a archery pro shop.
Most people have those.
I know there's one down here in San
Diego,
performance archery.
Um,
I met Scott Eastwood at one in Riverside
and I think it's called Riverside
archery back home.
It's a bottle rack,
but there's these pro shops if that's
what they do every day.
So the key with any hunter,
any archery hunting you're going to do
shooting that Bo and shooting it
consistently,
getting those reps in.
And that's where,
you know,
you can't control the experience you
get.
You know,
that kind of comes slowly.
But like what you've taken control of is
the repetition and the discipline was
shooting an Arrow and doing it
accurately.
So once you control that part of it,
the hunting experience is going to come.
The stock experience,
the learning,
the animals that's going to come.
But at least when you get that
opportunity be able to make the shot.
So for what I fought for new people who
are interested,
get to an archer pro shop,
get set up with the good bow,
learn how to shoot correctly and do it a
lot,
and then you branch out and set up the
hunts.
It's just so difficult to execute a
shot.
An animal.
Yeah,
it was way different.
People don't have any idea how much
anxiety and how much adrenaline is
pumping through your system when you're
drawn back on an animal.
Yeah.
I mean the consequences are so grave.
Everything is so high stakes.
It's just,
it's,
you only get this one shot like here it
is.
And especially say if you're on a back
country hunt,
you go 20 miles in,
there's,
there's 190 inch mule deer just standing
there,
hey feeding and you get this one shot.
This is your one shot.
Even,
you haven't seen a deer in six days to
finally see a deer and you draw back and
your arms are shaking and you just try
and trying to go through your shot
process without flinching and fucking
panicking and just slamming that trigger
like it's fucking door in a monster or
something of his line of it.
People want a shortcut.
And I was the same way.
I'd been on hunts like that.
I've been on,
um,
nate semans me on a hunt where I was in
the Eagle cap wilderness and I don't,
I'm trying to,
or I'm trying to think if,
yeah,
we didn't see
God,
I don't,
I want to say we didn't see an elk for
something like six days.
I killed a buck on day seven,
I think,
and a bowl on day eight.
But there was a long time in there.
Whereas like,
what are we doing?
Yeah.
So it's really easy when you finally do
get that opportunity to want to shortcut
from seeing it,
to holding the antlers in your hands and
being successful.
And that's where people rush it.
They get back and they just want to get
that air.
A lot of it's way anxiety cause as
sooner an arrow can be going towards
that animal that feel like the closer
they are to holding that animal to make
it a good shot.
But man,
you still have to go.
If you,
you can't skip a step.
Anxiety's a crazy thing man.
Yeah,
it's a crazy thing.
It's like that adrenaline and that the
feeling of discomfort.
It is like this like uncertainty
feeling.
Yeah.
It's just very hard for people to
handle.
But that's with the case of the anything
where you have to perform anything where
it's difficult to do,
where you're just like,
oh my God,
is it happening?
It's happening right now.
Well,
ah yeah.
The brain is so,
it's wired with all these different
chemicals that are excreta.
When that,
when that moment's happening,
when when there's a this final event,
this is it.
Here it is.
All my God ready action.
That's where I think all the reps you've
put in paid off cause on that first
buck.
So it was 15 minutes into the hut.
It was even Alec who's been doing that
for 30 years has never had a hunt that
played out that quickly,
that perfectly.
But I think you told me,
um,
I'm always,
I'm always trying to get into the,
to the heads of other hunters and,
and just wanting to know what the
thought process is.
But I think you told me that when you're
in bow range of that buck right out of
the gate on the early in the hunt,
didn't you take a few deep breaths and
relaxed and you say that.
Yeah.
And that's a lot of people,
their tents,
their tents because there's so much
going on,
they never relax and that shot is just
not going to be accurate.
But when you can relax and then just
like in your backyard,
you come and you focus,
you're just as calm as you've done a
thousand times and you can pick that
spot,
level,
that bubble and slowly squeeze that
trigger.
That's when it works.
That's super hard to do.
Well it was,
it was happening so fast before we knew
it.
We kicked her shoes off and we're
walking,
you know,
just with socks on.
Yeah.
Just creeping through the grass and we
got to 45 yards and he's like,
do you want to get closer?
I'm like,
this is perfect.
Stop right here.
Younger.
Got It.
Yeah.
And I just went,
just took a couple of deep ones.
Yeah.
And it was feeding and then I'm like,
okay,
I know what to do.
And just did it.
And when,
when they'll walk,
when I heard the impact of the arrows
was like,
holy shit.
There it is.
Yeah.
That was a perfect execution.
It's a weird feeling,
man.
When does like did that really happen?
Did that really happen?
Then we're standing over the the,
and then I sent you a picture of it.
I said boom.
Yeah.
And that was,
I say,
perfect execution,
not of killing the animal of the shot.
Is it perfect execution of the shot?
I'm not saying we were executing animals
that people don't understand.
It's hard to do.
It's not,
there's so much physical action involved
in pulling a bow back and being in
perfect position and making sure you're
not torquing the bow and leveling the
bubble on the site and,
and pulling with the back muscles and
making sure everything's in line and
there's no flinching or extra movement
and you're concentrating on the exact
spot.
You want that Arrow to hit as the things
releasing all under extreme anxiety and
pressure and this thing,
is it moving?
Is it going to keep walking?
What's going to happen?
And there's so much involved,
but the feeling when it's over the
relief and then knowing that I'm going
to have this organic meat,
it is the most delicious meat in the
world and I'm going to be cooking and I
can't wait to cook it.
Yeah.
And I haven't cooked any of it,
but,
um,
I can't wait.
I'm going to cook some tonight.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
I think it's a,
it's a powerful experience for almost
anybody and it's one that I know not
everybody can hunt and under ray who
listens to this is,
is probably ever going to hunt.
But those that do will understand,
you know,
and it's not always going to be
comfortable.
It's not always killing an animal,
is not,
people aren't going to have warm and
fuzzy feelings about seeing an animal
dead,
but they are going to,
there's something about taking
responsibility for the meat that you're
eating.
And that's going to be,
I don't know if relief is the right
word,
but it's,
uh,
it's just that connection that I think
they're gonna it's gonna make more
sense.
Well,
one thing that confuses people with you
is when they find out that you run ultra
marathons and you're working out all the
time,
like why is he doing all that stuff?
You're like,
well,
I do that to be my very best when I'm in
the mountains,
when I'm hunting people.
I've seen people go,
what?
Like,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
You work out every day,
you run twice a day,
you run ultra marathons,
but to test yourself so that when you're
hunting,
you could be at your very best.
Yeah.
That's right.
I don't think people understand how much
it means to me.
Uh,
I feel like I owe it to the animal to be
at my best.
I feel like if the animal suffers longer
than then I believe it should.
That's,
I don't like dealing with that.
I don't like that.
So I feel like I,
there's a weight of that on my shoulder,
shoulders where I need to be at my best
as a hunter.
And to do that,
I put in work,
I prepare every day and I just want to
know that I'm going to be merciful when
it comes time to kill the animal.
But you're also going to be in shape
enough to get to position to get to the
animal and have your heart rate dropped
down.
And also the state calm.
Yeah.
This is why you do so much cardio.
Yup.
And uh,
you know,
on this hunt,
I've felt all that worked out exactly
how it was supposed to.
Um,
quick,
very quick clean deaths and then,
you know,
like in the buck that I killed just a
couple of days ago,
that second buck,
I was able to,
you know,
there's something about putting the a
dead animal on your shoulders and
packing it out that uh,
you know,
it's just part of the process.
It just feels right.
Yeah.
But for a lot of people that seem so
crazy,
like,
wait a minute,
you run a marathon a day so that you
could be in shape to go hunting.
Yeah.
Can't you just go hunting?
You can.
A lot of people do.
I'm not,
I'm not here.
I'm not here to judge anybody or to tell
somebody that they need to do what I do
or they're doing it wrong.
I'm saying that's what people that,
you know,
hunting is such a personal journey.
You know,
when people say maybe hunting is fun for
some people,
maybe for some people it is fun to kill
an animal.
I don't know.
For me it's not,
and people said,
Oh,
you couldn't admit it.
It's fun.
I'm like,
it's not fun.
It's like,
I know what it means to me.
What it means to me is I need to be at
my very best to be at my very best.
I need to run a marathon a day.
I need to work harder than I've ever
worked.
So I'm at the top of my game on the
hunt.
I don't care what you think about that.
Or I don't care about your mindset.
I'm not talking about you.
I'm talking about me.
And that's,
people have a hard time with that.
Will they have a hard time believe in
first of all that you run a marathon a
day.
Even you saying that,
I'm like,
imagine if I didn't know this guy.
I feel like he's full of Shit.
Yeah.
And it's not a fucking meme on her
marathon.
He's supposed to take six months off and
do nothing.
It's true.
Say,
yeah,
it's true.
You know,
it's a man,
you know,
and it's not all at what time.
It's what I do is I get
up in the morning,
I'll get six miles done faster,
cardio,
uh,
and people.
Then people also like to,
to say why they don't do it is because,
well,
I spend time with my family.
It's like,
shut the fuck up.
I spent time with my family too.
So anyway,
I get up while they're still sleeping,
they're sleeping.
What am I supposed to do?
So let's go lay in bed by him.
Wait,
come on.
I want to spend time with you.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I go before anybody's up.
The second time I run is that lunch and
I got to get out of the office.
I got a regular nine to five job.
Drives me insane because I'm meant to be
in the mountains.
But Hey,
I got a job.
It's the best job I've ever had.
I'm,
I want to do a good job for the company
I work for.
Been there 21 years,
but to be at my best there,
I need a break at lunch.
So I say,
they'd said,
well,
Hey,
do you want to be superintendent of the
water department?
I'm like,
yeah,
I'll be superintendent,
but I'm going to run every day at lunch.
And if they would've said,
no,
you can't do that.
I'm like,
well,
I'm not going to be superintendent then.
But they said,
okay,
yeah,
you can do that.
I'm like,
all right,
I'll come in early,
I'll stay late,
we'll make it work.
So I,
that's my second one.
I can't spend time with my family at
lunch.
They're not going to come to my work and
sit in the lunch room with me.
So I go running.
Um,
and how far do you run at lunch?
At lunch,
I'll try to get,
if I,
if I'm trying to get a marathon done a
day,
I don't go to the mountain.
I just go flat and I get at least 13
dental lunch.
So combined 19.
Yep.
Before you even get home.
So then the last run of the day,
on my way home from work,
I'll go to the mountain and I'll get
that last seven or eight done.
And that's free runs a day.
And that'll be a marathon a day.
That's a lot of fucking running now.
It's not,
it's not for you because it was fine.
I don't feel,
I feel 100% healthy.
I don't feel banged up.
I don't feel anything.
And I,
that's a question I always get.
Well,
how do you,
people say,
well,
how do you recover and how do you,
or do you have so much muscle at?
First of all,
I weigh 170 pounds.
I'm not,
I don't have like muscle everywhere.
So I'm not big.
But I also eat meat all the time.
Every day.
You know,
you talked about the lions and wherever
with the river and they were eating just
buffalo and they were jacked.
You got to have protein.
So if you can run a marathon a day,
if you're eating salad,
you're going to wait 140 pounds.
Okay?
If you run a marathon a day and you're
eating steak three times a day,
you're going to retain some muscle.
So that's what I do.
I know what my body needs for calories,
and I know when I'm at my best,
it's when I have excess calories to
burn.
So that's what I do.
I make sure I'm eating nonstop.
But you're also lifting weights.
I do.
How do you have the time to do all this?
I'm like listening to the schedule.
I'm like,
this is ridiculous.
And then you shoot your bow.
Yeah.
And then you hang out with your family.
What?
And so campaigns,
the family,
the family time is about from a c I'll
get home at about six 30 till about and
then everybody will be going to bed at
10 so that's Fox time.
You know there's duck,
oh,
you fucking watches Fox News.
Well,
in the evenings,
that's really what you watch.
We watched the coins.
Goddamn,
these liberals,
we like watch the voice.
No.
Or American Luke's on the American art
or on American idol.
Luke Bryan's on there.
So we'll actually have a little bit
sometimes my daughter.
So that's what me and my daughter do.
She loves the voice and uh,
and so it's fine.
It's fine to get into that.
So that's what I do.
And I can,
if I'm just doing the close reps,
like during the workweek,
it's generally just out of my house,
just you know,
20 yards shooting my bow and that's,
and it's just,
and then when I'll lift on Monday,
Wednesday,
Friday I lift right after work and I'll
go outlaw strength and you know,
sometimes nick the trainer Dude hammered
out,
I'll take it home at the same time.
So on those days I'm not going to get a
marathon done a day on those three days.
Do you feel like shit on those days
because you didn't get your marathon
then?
No,
because lifting his heart they lifted in
his hard.
But I,
I in the back,
I'll be honest,
I'm not normal,
I get it.
But in the back of my mind I'm thinking
I kind of suck a little bit cause I
didn't get a marathon done.
That is so crazy.
Yeah.
That's my thinking.
Like when you run an ultra and to save,
you run a hundred miles or more.
When w w what kind of demons are going
through your head when you're out there
running?
Um,
I don't,
I don't know if it's,
I don't know what it is.
It's a
like the Moab to 40.
You rent 238 miles in three days.
What were you thinking while you were at
day two and a half?
Thinking is I'm,
I'm honoring myself by getting the
absolute most out of my,
I don't think I've,
I've reached my limit I think.
I think if you're not getting the most
out of your body,
you're not,
you're not taking advantage of your
life,
that you're not honoring your life.
So to me,
I need to find what my limit is.
I can't halfway it.
I can't halfway because I feel like then
I'm not,
man,
that's not,
I dunno,
I can't live with myself if I,
if I don't feel like I've,
I'm giving,
I have given everything that I have.
The weird thing about running is like as
you run more,
your capacity to run more increases.
So you realize like,
oh,
like the body has more capability than
you think because you just have to get
accustomed to this amount of work and
then you can just do it all the time and
then it gets used to it and then it
grows and expands.
And then your threshold and what your
expectations are.
They increased too.
So in the beginning you were saying that
when you first started running,
like running a five k is like,
holy shit,
this is hard.
Or a 10 K is brutal.
You would never think like,
man,
can I do a marathon now?
You're fucking doing a marathon every
day.
Yeah.
And this is the same person.
It's not like,
you know,
you are.
I've always,
first time I started running,
I ran a fucking ultra marathon.
You know,
it's not,
no,
no.
And that's,
I mean,
that's everything.
That's everybody and everything.
You work up to it.
And so that it's no different from me.
I just feel like I'm finally getting to
my potential and I wasted a lot of years
not living up to my potential.
So I,
when I do the running videos and I'm
smiling,
I'm in a good mood.
That's genuine cause I'm like,
this is my potential.
You know,
I can't be happy sitting at home
watching t I'm going to do it because I
love my family.
I'm going to hang out and do that,
but I can't be,
I don't feel like that's my potential.
This,
this is the thing that I think is very
important for people like you and I
think a lot of people,
it's that in achieving goals and in
pushing hard,
there's a release of anxiety that I
think overwhelmed a lot of people for
most of their life.
Most of,
I know a lot of people that are
overwhelmed by anxiety and most of those
people that I know that are overwhelmed
by anxiety don't push themselves.
I think there's a connection there and I
think that physically pushing yourself
to your limit all the time,
whether it's lifting weights or Jujitsu
or running or whatever,
you do that strenuous,
I think it's a requirement for the human
body that we think of as an option.
I don't think it's an option.
I don't think so.
Especially not for mental health.
I think.
I think it's really critical.
I think really hard exercises.
One,
and I don't care what you do,
whether you're swimming or whatever you
like,
whatever you enjoy mountain biking.
But I think really hard exercise is one
of the most important requirements for
like a happy,
healthy life.
I really do.
I think,
you know,
man,
I could say that maybe I tried to
justify what I do to try to put logic to
it.
And maybe even what you're saying is,
is,
is a little bit of justification.
I don't know.
So I dunno if what I do is right or what
we should be doing.
I don't know.
I just know how I feel when I do it,
but that doesn't mean I don't have
regret sometimes.
Like even with my kids now that they're
older and,
uh,
you know,
I,
I really struggled wondering if the
message I had been sending to my family
about average is a failure.
If you're not giving your best,
you're not honoring your life basically.
And then I'm like,
maybe that's okay for some people.
Maybe not everybody needs to run a
marathon a day and they're fine and
they're happy.
It's like,
who am I to say what makes somebody else
happy?
Just like I get mad when somebody tells
me how I should feel.
I can't say why they need.
And so then I was like,
here's my kids.
My boys who are great young men strong,
um,
have all the potential in the world.
Have I somehow have,
I said,
being just a regular guy who has a job
when it comes home,
there's something wrong with that.
And I'm like,
God did I screw up?
And it's just like,
that's really been bothered.
Cause my son quit a good job as a
deputy,
my oldest and he joined the army because
he says he has more to offer this world.
That's hard.
Is it hard because well it's hard first
of all because your son is joining the
military and you're like,
wow,
my son could go to combat and I could
lose him.
Yeah.
But is it also hard because you feel
like your high expectations for yourself
might have set a bar for him then maybe
doesn't line up with his initial
expectations?
You've made him think that whatever
might have made him happy before is not
good.
Right.
And that I,
that's what I thought.
And I,
you know,
I was like,
it was,
uh,
it was hard to deal with when he was
leaving.
And I'm like,
God,
what did I do?
Right.
And,
uh,
so,
you know,
I told him,
I,
I'm sorry if I ever made you feel that
that being a regular average person,
there was something wrong with that.
And he said,
you know,
the example that I've set growing up was
that,
uh,
to work hard and achieve big goals and,
and that's,
and that's what he wants to do.
And so he,
he said,
you know,
he said that was for him.
And then my,
my younger son,
who's in his third year of college now,
he,
I had the same talk with him and I just
said,
um,
you know,
I'm sorry if if I've done something to
make it feel like,
you know,
being,
being average was a failure.
And he said that,
uh,
he wants to graduate and he wants to
join the service and maybe try to go to
special forces too for the same reason.
And so I dunno,
I dunno.
They don't act,
they act completely fine with it and
they'd love,
you know,
they love working hard and have big
goals to achieve and um,
that part feels good.
But sometimes I wonder if,
you know,
I dunno,
I just second guess myself,
I guess.
Yeah,
it's hard,
high expertise
and you put on kids,
it's very difficult.
Like you want to say,
I just want them to be happy.
I just want them to live their lives on
their path and everyone,
like every kid has their own personality
and you know,
your three kids are all uniquely
different in their own way.
And who's to say,
who's to say?
I think all you can do is live by
example and,
and support them and let them make the
choices that they decided to make.
The problem is the choices that they've
made are,
you know,
very stressful and very dangerous.
And you know,
I mean it might turn out to,
they might turn out like Tim Kennedy or
someone like Andy Stumpf be an awesome
human being,
but it's for you as a parent,
this is this incredibly stressful
pressure filled situation where you have
to reevaluate how you raised them.
And what I always,
my,
what I told them growing up always was,
I don't care if you're the best at
whatever you're doing,
but cause,
cause not everybody can be the best.
But I said,
just give your best just be or best.
And so that's where I see if they're
coasting or whatever.
I'm like,
I think he got some more,
you got some more in you.
And that's all I ever wanted.
But the things about people that coast
about stuff,
if they have like a thought of doing
better and they just don't put in the
effort,
they feel like shit.
Yeah.
You know,
you,
they feel like shit for you telling them
that,
but they feel like shit for shit,
for not doing well to yeah.
Yeah.
Especially if they have ambition.
If he unrealized potential as a fairy
fucking horrible feeling,
you know,
unrealized potential and unrealized
expectations are just,
it's like this feeling that you haven't
done enough,
we'll keep you up at night.
It will fuck with your head.
And that's,
I just know how I felt,
not giving all I got and I,
I don't want,
I didn't want my kids to feel like that,
so I was just like,
make sure you're giving your best,
be your best.
That's it.
And,
um,
but then I,
then I was like,
what am I done?
Yeah.
So it's,
you know,
I can only speak for myself.
Um,
you know,
when I,
when it,
when tanner was born,
I was young.
Um,
I don't,
you know,
being a parent,
it's like,
I feel like I'm better now than I was
when I was 24 years old.
And um,
you know,
hopefully I'm pretty,
maybe more,
I'm different with my daughter.
She's also a girl.
So it's,
it is just,
that's different.
But man,
it's like there's no blueprint on how to
be the perfect parent,
and now I'm like,
I hope I did okay.
Yeah,
there's no blueprint.
I mean,
what's the blueprint?
And be,
be honest.
Give them the best version of your
thoughts on life that you can give them,
spend time with them when you can.
Yeah.
Then what is the,
what is the blueprint?
I mean,
just try to help them figure out their
path in life.
And it's also hard too,
because you've got a full time job.
I mean,
how much time do you dedicate to them?
You know,
how much time can you have?
Yeah,
I mean it'd be be great if I'd be like,
Oh,
I'm not going to work anymore.
I'm just going to hang out with the kids
all day.
I mean,
it's not realistic.
Yeah.
And you can't do it.
And then also to be the example I felt
like I would need to set for the kids so
they'd believe they can achieve whatever
they wanted to.
I had to put in work myself.
I can't say you can be amazing.
While I'm half asking stuff.
When you say that you didn't reach your
full potential until like later in life,
like when do you feel like that was?
I
haven't,
no,
but I mean like you realize that you
like really pushing to reach your full
potential.
Now.
I still don't think I have,
I buy you're pushing towards it.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm doing more.
And so I'm,
when did that change?
Um,
God,
I don't know.
Maybe,
maybe when I did my first hundred,
so that's 2009 I felt what,
what sacrifice real sacrifice was.
And
I dunno,
I,
you know,
hard hunts when Roy and I would do super
hard hunts,
I'd felt like I was given all I got
backpack haunts into the back country.
Yeah.
2008.
I mean,
I always did.
I did hard hunts by myself and Eagle
Cap,
but there's not really a great chance of
dying in the Eagle Cap.
You know,
it's a,
you could,
but,
um,
you know,
that I felt like I was,
I was given all I had on,
on the hunts that required the most of
me.
And then at that same time,
so that was 2007,
2008.
Um,
then at the same time I was also ramping
up what I did with running and pushing
my body 100 milers and things like that
because you realize that you needed more
endurance.
I just realized that I had,
I had,
I've been doing what I've been telling
my kids not to do.
I've been coasting,
you know,
it still was more than a lot of people
are doing.
But to me it felt like I wasn't living
up to my full potential.
So I'm like,
you know,
I want to do more.
And then that led to my lab and um,
and when I,
when I meet people and see people that
are doing amazing things,
it's just,
it shows me what's possible.
And so that's why I know I can,
I have more offer.
That's a fascinating thing.
But you know,
used to take these steps towards this
journey and then you realize as you're
making these steps that your capacity
for work is increasing.
So you have to push yourself further to
test your body.
And then,
you know,
a,
a marathon seems out of reach,
but then a marathon becomes a normal
thing.
And then a 50 miler and then a hundred
miler than the 205 mile and a 238 mile
hour.
And now you were talking the other day
with,
I guess candace was considering a 500
miler.
Yeah,
yeah.
She asked and I know,
uh,
that Shit's ridiculous.
And I said,
both said we do it and it would just be
amazing.
It would be,
you know,
Walter.
Yeah.
And so that's,
I mean,
that's what people that do those type of
races live for the next big challenge.
And you know,
when you haven't,
when he can cross a finish line,
like I did Moab and Courtney did she,
you know,
dominate,
she had a great race and that race,
but she,
you know,
when you can finish a finish line and
you're smiling,
you're like,
ah.
Dot.
A little more.
Got some more left.
So,
so that's why,
you know,
the sound of something epic 500
nonstop is,
is so incredible.
That sounds so insane that you'd run 238
miles.
It'd be basically halfway done.
Yeah,
that sounds stupid.
I know.
But listen,
when we were a hundred miles in,
yeah,
a hundred miles is a long way.
And I told my brother was with me,
Taylor.
I go,
you know,
it's,
it's a different thought when you're not
even halfway and you've just done a
hundred.
100 is hertz.
Yeah.
But you're not halfway.
So it's the same thing.
It's a,
it's really not that.
It's just a change in mindset.
How many days do you think you need to
run?
500.
Well,
I need a year.
Can I do that?
Yeah.
Can I have a year?
I need 10 hours of sleep at night.
I was listening to the Matthew Walker
Dr. Matthew Walker said 10 hours.
Just like God.
Yeah.
Courtney told me she slept one minute.
Yes.
Yeah,
I had,
uh,
one,
no,
she,
she slept 27 minutes total.
She laid down for 20 minutes and she
couldn't sleep.
Yeah.
And then the one time that she slept,
she slept for one minute.
I did that exact,
Taylor was there and I did the exact
same thing for one minute because he was
watching the watch and I fell asleep.
There's a picture and I woke up.
I was like,
how long was I sleep?
He goes a minute.
I'm like,
what's the go?
And for whatever reason,
that minute it does something,
I don't know what does it do?
But she's,
she had,
I don't have no idea.
Said she woke up and she was angry that
they let her sleep so long.
Whoever was there,
she thought it was longer and he was
like,
no,
you only slept for a minute.
Oh Shit.
Well let's go.
Yeah,
that's,
that's one thing I learned in that first
200 I did,
uh,
Richard won that race and that was a
mistake I made is um,
I was asking how,
how long he'd been sleeping.
That was what you said.
He sent me a quote,
but you said he'd go fucking Richard.
Cause he is like,
and he said that he says I was the
greatest day of my life and Joe Rogan
said,
fuck Richard Kessler.
But,
uh,
but he's,
he was sleeping short durations like 15
minutes and I didn't realize that your
body will reset that quick.
You thought you needed to like an hour.
Yeah,
yeah.
Makes Sense.
Yeah.
And plus,
you know,
I'm sitting here,
it's not like it's,
I'm God,
it's really hard to be good at ultra
marathoning and also be able to want to
pack an elk.
I muscle weigh what I weigh is not going
to,
so I kind of throwing myself in the
category of Richard and in Courtney as
like can't my,
I can't do it at what I do.
So I'm trying to be beat the best of
both worlds.
And it's just,
you're going to give up in both being
built like Zack bitter,
who's like one 440 is use ran.
He,
he's the one who ran the,
he was on the podcast last week and he
ran the US record of a hundred miles in
11 hours and 40 minutes averaging seven
minutes and 41 or 702 what was it?
Yeah.
So to me,
11 hours and 40 minutes.
So I think he ran,
yeah,
seven minute crazy seconds per mile,
which is right.
Fucking madness.
That's,
that's amazing.
So fast.
And he's so impressive.
And he's a mediator.
Oh,
is leads meet.
he's like basically on a carnivore diet.
He,
it's like steak constantly.
He's on a very high fat diet.
High Fat,
high stake,
high stake and protein diet.
Yeah.
Well it's so,
yeah.
I mean to be that,
to be the optimal endurance athlete,
ultra endurance athlete in the
mountains,
you need to be lighter.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm just way too much.
But to be able to pack out an animal,
you need to have some weight on.
I'm doing it to,
to be the best at hunting.
I'm not doing it to be the best runner.
And I'm not saying I could be,
I don't have the talent that I,
I'm pretty tough,
but I mean,
they,
they're super tough and super talented.
What is a talent for running?
What's the talent?
Left foot.
Right foot.
It's not,
you know what I'm saying?
It's not like you're painting.
There's a talent there.
You know there's a [inaudible] it's
endurance.
Yeah.
I don't know if that's a towel,
but it's theirs.
It's having great endurance is a thing.
It's certainly a thing.
Yeah.
And managing the body to get the most
out of that endurance.
Most of it is,
is in,
Courtney said this too,
she didn't realize how far she could
push in the paint shoes in.
So her first hundred she quit first
hundred mile or she dropped out of,
because she was in pain.
That was it.
And she's like,
I can't do this.
And then she quit and she's like,
wait a second.
I equipped for no reason.
I quit just because I was in pain.
So then after that she realized pain is
just part of the deal and has it quit
since.
And so she just didn't realize that the
pain quotient of those races,
yeah.
It doesn't feel good.
Just cause the full,
it doesn't feel good.
Doesn't mean you stop.
Right.
Yeah.
So,
and that's,
that's the key.
Most people can't push that push through
that amount of pain.
It hurts,
you know,
it's the worst pain I've ever felt.
But what hurts the most?
It depends.
It's like I've run and my foot started
hurting.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
this is it.
I probably broke my foot,
maybe stress fracture.
Then all of a sudden my other knee
hurts.
I'm like,
oh my,
okay my,
my ligament is got tight cause I got
dehydrated as rubbing on my bone.
And it's like,
oh wait,
no,
this other right hip hurt.
It's just like everything hurts.
Different things.
Your feet get beat up,
you get blisters,
you're getting dried out.
So things are just,
things are different in your body.
Um,
like I got a bone on top of my foot that
rubs and if I get dried out,
that stuff's not sliding well enough.
So that rubs in,
it swells up more.
So it's just like all sorts of things
happen.
Yeah.
People want everything to feel good
doing it.
Felt comfortable.
And it does.
You shouldn't push too hard for about
five miles.
Just be comfortable.
You should just be comfortable.
Yeah.
So that's the biggest thing as people.
Um,
and you know,
there's this guy too that's,
that's been following me.
I love,
I love the guy.
And he's like,
so he sees a pictures,
he follows along.
He's like,
well I want to do a hundred miler and
cause it sounds amazing.
Right.
And uh,
signed up to do 101 my brother just just
did recently.
It's called Badger Mountain and uh,
hadn't done it before.
I think he came and ran Pisca did about
four summers,
one's about 16 miles or whatever and
went out and he's going to do a hundred
mile or after that.
And um,
started throwing up.
But like mile 30 threw up like 13 times
and couldn't walk,
was dehydrated throwing up and it was a
hardest thing to do,
but he had to drop and that,
so there's your getting your body to a
place where you can run that far and
then,
so that's part,
he hasn't been there yet.
And I think part of that was he wasn't
taking his salt.
There's a lot of,
a lot of things that go on with pushing
your body that hard,
but he got 50 miles done for,
for me,
I thought that was a great success
because just people just because they
want to run a hundred doesn't mess
necessarily mean you're going to,
there's a lot of things that have to go
into preparation and the tactics and
fueling and everything else.
Learning just like courtney did,
learning just like he did,
he got 50 in and now we signed up for
big foot,
so he's going to do 205 miles you,
so he's going from dropping out at 5,205
miles.
Yep.
And I think he can do,
it's a sickness.
You guys are all sick in the head.
I'd guys are all getting sick together.
I think he can do it.
But,
and that's just as part of the process
of learning what you're capable of and
it's not,
it doesn't happen like that.
When you say take the salts and like
what are you,
what are you doing?
Uh,
they're called s caps,
so it's just salt pills.
But I thought saw,
gives you high blood pressure and it's
bad for you.
It's,
you're,
you're right.
But when you're sweating nonstop,
it doesn't give you high blood pressure
folks.
It's not bad for you.
Okay.
So it's a fucking bad study from like
the 1970s that people recite salts in a
central mineral.
Um,
so when you're,
when you're doing it,
how much you taken in it?
Take,
I take salt every hour.
And how much salt?
Couple pill.
Couple of capsules of s caps.
So it's a couple of capsules and if you
don't,
you won't make it really?
No.
Wow.
Nope.
So it's just your body just gets too
dehydrated.
Yeah.
Two deficient.
And what is the water in the salt?
Like how does it,
what does it,
what does,
what's happening when you're taking
salt?
Uh,
I dunno,
but you know,
everybody does it.
Yeah.
I'm not sure exactly,
but all I know is like,
I remember the first time I did,
western states had only done it once,
but it was a 100 miler in 2010 and I got
to mile 55 I think.
And I was dragging ass.
You come out of the canyons a super hot
and there is,
you know,
nineties or a hundred it's in the canyon
so he can pop out on to mile 55 and I
was hurting and uh,
and Sean mize and her who's been a very
good ultra runner for a long time.
He's like,
if you take assault on my,
no I haven't.
So he gave me some salt right then and
it made,
it took a little while but made the
biggest difference that just salt.
So you had never taken salt before?
I hadn't,
I didn't take it the first 55 miles.
Oh Wow.
So then you,
you just got to get in that community
and understand what they do and how they
survive and how they fuel.
How many people were doing that?
Like say if you do big foot,
how many people were entering the race?
When I did it,
which was two years ago,
is I think 70 [inaudible] now I think
she's over over a hundred and all these
races.
Wow.
It's a,
yeah.
What candice bird always says is 200 200
is the new 100 or one what?
What used to be a hundred it was like a
long way.
It now is 200 200 is a new 100 and when
did this change?
When did it shift over that like maybe
2016 I did big foot maybe right in
there.
That's really recent.
Yeah.
So this whole sport,
it's kind of evolving right now.
Hundreds.
The two hundreds are and it's evolving
based on how far people can that are
willing to push themselves are
continuing to go past the boundaries.
Yeah.
So when this 500 does take place,
when did I think that's going to happen?
She hopes to do it next year.
You got to quit your job.
Quit your job.
That's an all day though.
I'd,
I'd love to hear sneaker sponsor.
Yeah.
Oh,
I got an agent.
I'm like,
got along.
I had to run another one.
I'm going to be your agent taking over
from here.
Okay.
Do it.
Yeah.
You can't sell yourself.
I'm going to sell,
you know,
I've,
yeah,
I've terrible.
I've definitely terrible.
At business.
Well,
you can't be good at everything.
Yeah.
That's a fact.
It's not possible.
The number one thing I hate more than
anything is when business screws up my
passions.
So when I hate the business of hunting,
it sounds weird because I'm probably
sitting here because of the business of
hunting,
but I can't stand it.
I know what you're saying.
The business of like the industry
involved in hunting gear,
it goods and all that stuff.
Yeah.
I love hunting.
I love the connection with animals.
I love doing what I do and I know I have
value.
I get it.
I mean,
I have value because it put my name on
stuff and they sell it.
I hate it.
That's probably what you're good at it.
I Dunno.
I think those two are correlated.
You know?
I'm fucking terrible at the business
part of comedy,
you know?
I mean,
I just,
I just want to do it.
I don't,
I don't like thinking about the money
part.
Yeah,
I don't,
that's why I have managers
and agents,
right.
They take care of everything so that I
can just be free.
And if you're not,
I,
you know,
you only have certain amount of
resources and if you put all your
resources into the business side,
how are you going to have the
concentration to do all the other things
you're doing?
Right.
Practice shooting and running,
all the,
all the different things all the time.
They'll fuck with your head too.
You got to,
and this is one of the things that I was
thinking of when my phone didn't work
for four days or three days,
whatever it was,
was that how much time I'm wasting,
how much energy I'm wasting.
Yeah.
Like you can only interact so much with
other people's thoughts and ideas and
information and you,
you have a lot of things already in your
head that you're going over and thinking
about and managing and the more shit you
stuff in there,
it doesn't make you better at doing
those original things.
It dilutes it.
Yes.
And it also diluted my,
my peace of mind.
Like
I think you know,
did you,
you only have certain amount of
resources in your life and you have to
choose what's important to you and
what's not.
You know,
and I think it's real easy to get
distracted.
It's real easy to flood your brain with
nonsense.
I think so.
Yeah.
I'm not,
I'm good at a few things.
So I try to focus on those.
Yeah,
I'm not,
and that the business part.
Yeah.
You can take that over for me.
Yeah,
I'll take it over for you.
I'm not even good at it,
but I'm good at,
I'm good at what I'm good at is I know
people that I like and what I like about
them and what's interesting about them
and I like promoting people.
Like it's one of the things that I've,
I've gotten out of this podcast that is
a,
there's a lot of things that have gotten
out of this podcast that are really like
unexpected and peripheral,
but one of them is the ability to make
my friends famous.
Yeah.
Like this podcast is made,
Joey Diaz famous and Ari Shaffir famous
and Duncan trussell famous.
All these people that I think are
amazing that are,
hello,
I got a chance to let other people know
about them.
And that's not the only reason why that
became famous.
They became famous because they're
talented,
but it gave them this unusual platform.
Right.
And I,
that that means a lot to me to help
people.
Like that's something that's very,
very rewarding to me.
And it's almost along the same lines of
being able to provide as a hunter and
provide food,
like to be in a provide to let people
know you gotta you gotta see this guy's
guy's awesome are even things people
that I even,
I don't even know people like their
documentary.
I see a documentary.
It's fucking amazing.
I want to tell people about it.
I like promoting things and without any
expectation of something coming back to
me in return.
I like,
I just like tea.
Like people,
um,
say like,
oh,
you know,
you're doing ads for products on your
instagram.
Never
have.
Yeah.
Everything that I've ever put up on
Instagram,
unless it's my own stuff,
unless it's like my fanny packs or
something that I sell,
anything that I've ever put put on,
like people's accuse me of like working
for vibe rooms,
five finger shoes.
I'm like,
no,
I liked him.
I don't want anything from them.
This is what I wear them all the time.
This is why I think they're good.
I think they build your feet up.
I know my feet are stronger cause I run
with these things.
It go,
you fucking,
she'll like,
no,
that's not what I'm doing.
And it's like that's the one thing of
having financial independence.
That's what's really rewarding is that I
don't have to think like that.
You know?
Like I haven't been offered,
uh,
to do ads on instagram.
I'm like,
no,
I can't because unless I,
unless it was something I super believed
in,
then I might,
I might consider doing it,
but I could never do it with some
nonsense like coca cola or something
like that because then skinny t,
what's that skinny t with skinny t.
I see the girls do it.
What a skinny t.
That's a thing on instagram.
I see this fucking guy.
I go to him,
he knows everything.
Hey,
all the young kids now he's got,
what's that called again?
What are you doing?
What's going on?
Uh,
he's a liaison,
but he's uh,
uh,
Dunkin say it.
Wherever he kept saying it,
wouldn't,
you know,
it's like popular.
Oh,
what's the term
I had was we talked about a dinner.
Yeah.
I don't remember doubles.
Dunkin just kept going on about Lil B.
I know it will be the base guy say like,
cause Gucci,
it's like the kids knew like there was a
word.
It's like guys.
Yes.
Oh Jamie.
Yeah,
Jamie's be,
I know what's floating.
And Jamie is online all day and he's
just ever,
ever since the Eddie Bravo podcast has
been blocking people.
Yeah.
So He's,
he's an unblocking rampage
people.
That's,
that's like most,
so what is skinny t is that detox to
you?
It's like a thing that people promote.
They posted a picture,
I drink my tea every day and it's making
detoxing and they're getting paid to
promote those.
Well wasn't a thing you were telling me
the Gary Vee was saying that,
you know,
you can get a lot of money for your
instagram posts.
I saw like on a good morning America
thing,
he did that.
If you have 100,000 followers,
I believe you can get up to about $5,000
per post.
That's crazy.
And ramp ramps up way high.
20 grand.
There was this 40 grand a post.
Yeah,
I've changed my tune.
I want to sell out now I'm offering my
services to anything that sucks.
There's this girl and I can't remember
who,
what she was in a movie camera.
She's Sorta of but kinda unique looking.
She was getting 65,000 and instagram
post and 20,000 a story post.
What?
Yeah.
She said she bought a house for doing,
wait a minute.
I need to sell out.
We do.
What do I,
what do I sell out to?
Who Do I sell out to?
Anybody.
Everyone vibrams much money.
You got,
you know,
I've been promoting you for free.
Uh,
you owe me.
No,
I can't.
The only thing I would ever promote his
eye,
it's like the same thing I feel about
the stuff that I promote for free.
It would have to be something that I
liked,
believed in.
Yeah,
it would have to like,
like hoyt,
if hoyt came to me and said,
will you,
I'm wearing a white hat,
would you promote our bowls?
I'm like,
fuck yeah,
shoot him every day.
They're awesome.
They actually put your picture up,
made you beautiful.
Put it up.
Well,
no,
I mean you joke around,
you weren't joking about you like
helping your friends,
but I don't know how long the powerful
Joe Rogan,
how long has it powerful.
Joe Rogan been around this saying,
yeah,
you know,
but the point is,
is like now that this is powerful
because if I put up,
hey,
where'd you hear about?
Or where did you start following me
from?
Or where'd you hear about what I do?
I don't eat 80% is Joe Rogan show Joe
Rogan experience.
And it's so it,
it's been a sane for a long time,
but it is powerful.
It was really crazy.
Bert Christ was at the airport and this
lady said she was in her sixties walked
up,
she goes,
powerful Burke Christ.
And he was like,
what the fuck?
And he texted me,
he goes,
dude,
that was crazy.
He's like,
this is like an older lady.
He said,
powerful Bert.
Kreischer all right.
And he was like,
whoa.
He goes,
that's when it hit me.
What the fuck?
I'm reaching like middle aged ladies.
Yeah.
It's past the middle aged ladies.
If she lives to be 120 that's a hell of
a lady.
No,
cause we're middle age.
We're middle age.
If everything goes perfect.
Yeah.
But with science today,
I think we're probably not even,
I think we're probably one third aged.
Yeah.
I think it's 100% easy today that
someone's going to live to be one 50 I
don't think there's any question
whatsoever.
Yeah.
What stem cell treatments and all this
other crazy nutter 50 yup.
Yeah.
I believe that.
I believe people that are alive today
because I think technology and medical
science is increasing its viability and
its potential so fast and there's so
many people working on things all the
time that if you do everything right
right now,
I think we're going to see people that
are alive today.
They're going to hit one 50 and I think
the people that are born like five years
from now,
10 years from now,
they'll probably hit 200 um whoa before
we go,
before we go Chicago,
UFC,
Ooh it's going to be a good one.
Colby Covington don't snap me.
Slap me.
And he said you're going to slap me.
Let's talking shit.
Lice.
You going to slap you.
Cause I was telling them that Jon Jones
might slap him.
Oh
I like colby.
I like what he's doing.
He's talking a lot of shit.
I'm just saying be careful who you talk
shit to.
Talking Shit to Jon Jones,
one of the baddest motherfucker has ever
lived.
You know he's making a lot of money.
He's being smart.
Oh cold reason why colby is fighting for
the title.
The reason why Colby is going to fight
Hofeld dos Anjos for the interim title
is not just because he's beaten good
guys cause he has,
he beat Damien Maia.
But it's more importantly that he's got,
he's gonna put asses in the seats.
Well that's part of the fight business
part of the fight business.
Now you've got to sell it.
I mean,
yeah,
especially in pre and post conor
mcgregor,
right.
And Post conor Mcgregor,
the fucking game has changed.
It's red panties night baby.
Everything is different.
It is.
And it's just like,
I see people hate on it on Colby for,
you know,
did he deserve the shot at all?
I know is he wins one fight.
He's holding the belt.
Yeah.
I mean if you look at one more beaten,
pull up his record.
Let me see his record.
If you look at who he's beaten in
comparison to somebody,
like there's some people that have been
calling him out that can't get a fight
with him,
like a Camaro.
Uzman wants to fight him and that guy is
a beast.
And then there's some other guys that
are really talented but haven't beaten
like any high level guys yet.
Uh,
okay.
So we lost a warley Alvarez and then
look at the guys he's beaten.
Brian Barbarian is a good guy.
Dumb Young Kim is a,
as a tough guy,
stung on cam and Damien Maia.
That is not really,
I mean I'm just going to be honest.
This is not a resume of someone who you
would normally see fighting for the
title right now.
I think he's fighting for the title
based,
not just on his beat beating Damien
Maia,
who's a really tough guy.
But I think on the fact that he's a
controversial,
very popular character.
Does he talk so much shit and because
he's talked so much shit about
Brazilians and he dominated my,
uh,
I mean it was,
it was a domination.
He dominated them and it's uh,
what,
what I was a big victory,
but that was his only big victory over a
titled a former title Challenger.
Yeah.
Who's like a top level guy who was also
40 years old,
right?
I mean Damien Maia is,
his best days are behind him.
Just as I say this as a huge Damien Maia
Fan.
Well I,
you know,
I look at it is you can't take too much
away from colby because I think of a lot
of great fighters say so if you say nate
Diaz who's been an icon for years,
one of my favorite of all time,
he's never fought for a title.
MM,
right.
Yeah.
No.
So if colby got there however he got
there,
he wins one more fight.
He's holding that belt.
I think about fighters who've come up
and maybe if they've been quiet or maybe
they haven't sold their fights,
maybe like as as well as colby has.
And so they've been grinding it out,
beating good guys.
Maybe because they've taken that slow
road.
Maybe somebody who gets lucky in one of
these fights and,
and catches him on the Chin and then
there two rungs back and then they got
to grind all the way back up.
That's a lot of damaged.
They're taking,
we're colby didn't have to,
I mean he played the game the right way
for today and it's paying off.
Yeah.
You want to is one loss.
I mean I think he's 11 and one now,
but you know,
but other people would say,
well look at guys like Anderson Silva
didn't talk any shit.
Just fuck people up,
you know?
And,
and became one of the greatest of all
time because of that.
Yeah,
that's true.
You know,
you could,
you could look at it like,
do you want to get that shot at the
title or do you want to be the greatest
that's ever done it?
Like how,
what is the difference?
I would rather get the title and then
show them the craters.
Right.
They're not mutually exclusive now.
Right now.
Yeah.
So I mean if he wins then he'll probably
get it a fight with Woodley.
Right?
Oh,
he will definitely get a fight with
Woodley if he wins 100% right.
So what if,
what if that happens?
And what if Woodley showed a video
today?
I don't even know if I'm the of
understand how the fuck he did this.
But tyron woodley has a video up on
instagram with him and a Tiki Golson and
uh,
he's hitting the pads.
He just had fucking shoulder surgery.
I mean he had shoulder surgery.
Like what?
Wash this.
I mean he had fucking shoulder surgery
like four months ago and he's firing up
the paths.
I don't even know how he did this.
Which shoulder?
That one.
That right?
Yes.
He looks like a freaking beast.
He is a fucking beast.
Oh my.
He's a legit beast.
Colby says he's a nerd.
Oh,
get the fuck out of here.
Just kidding.
He's talk shit about him.
Said he was break them.
He said he would break them,
but look,
you tiredly God,
he looks amazing.
He puts people to sleep.
It's just insane that that shoulder was
operated on.
Amazing.
I want to say like four months ago.
Yeah.
I don't even understand it.
That even make sense.
Impressive.
Like four months after shoulder surgery
is supposed to be like doing like the
little pink weights.
A chase shoes.
Yeah.
And pull out his class.
It's supposed to be doing this.
Oh well I don't,
I don't get it.
I mean,
but tyron is very smart and he's very
smart with his rehabilitation,
but he's doing prp and everything.
He can stem cells,
everything he can to rejuvenate all that
tissue.
But that's just,
that's insanely impressive and less and
less.
That is as old video that he's fucking
banked.
He's like,
these bitches,
I know what I'm going to do.
Maybe you want to leave.
I'm scared.
Yeah,
I have.
Wonderboy is furious.
Wonderboy is furious at Colby is getting
that shot.
Cause wonder boys like,
are you fucking kidding me?
How am I not fighting for the interim
title?
You know,
I just,
he just,
yeah,
he just beat Jorge Mas doll.
You know,
he had those two really close fights
with Woodley,
you know,
hit me.
He's,
he's beaten,
you know,
fucking who's who.
Yeah.
Well it's,
I get,
cause colby has worked out with me,
you know,
he's from or from the same town back
there.
And so people like,
I can't believe you support whatever.
Like colby go into,
he's a blah,
blah,
blah.
And it's just like he's just doing his
job.
I don't want,
no,
he's selling a cause game,
but this not how he is and real life.
Oh,
he's a great guy.
He like his,
him and his dad came and lifted with us.
They're,
they're the nicest people ever.
So it's just like,
it's a smart,
come on guys.
It's a smart move.
And it worked.
He did get hit in the head with a
boomerang for it though.
Hey,
you take take a little,
you know,
you take your sticky rumps you take your
lumps.
Yeah.
It happens.
It does happen.
All I know is he wins one more fight and
he's got the UFC belt.
How amazing is that?
The interim belt?
It's a belt is a belt.
I don't care what kind of a belt.
It's a belt.
Tyron Woodley calls it the booboo belt,
whatever,
because he's got an injury and that's
the only reason why they still super
shiny.
It's very shiny and it's still going to
be around his waist.
Yep.
If he wins.
True.
So it'll be in his fucking his trophy
cabinet.
Exactly.
The fucking belt.
Yeah.
So I think I've Po God.
I'm so pumped.
It's going to be,
you have some fun that's going to be a
that card pull up that June UFC card.
That is a killer card.
Um,
there's some real good fights on that
card.
Is that the card with Derek Lewis and
Francis and Ghana?
Oh God,
I don't think so.
Is it?
I want to say it is.
I don't think I want to say it is.
No.
What's ones that,
is that Vegas Whitaker Romero.
Oh,
Jesus made that a little bigger so daddy
can see what it reverses.
Romero and Romero,
his body.
He's a freak of freaks bro.
The freaker for overeem versus Curtis
Blades to Paul.
Ooh.
Cm punk versus Michael Jackson.
Both guys.
Holly's fighting.
Both guys are zero and one.
We are all the Holmes fight and Megan
Anderson.
Oh,
Marian Anderson's up.
Fucking killer,
Bro.
Megan Anderson is going to be your first
fight in UFC.
She's a legit beast and a challenge at
one 45.
Let's see.
Did as fuck.
Yeah.
Merseyside Beck.
Dick Versus Ricardo Lamas.
That's fucking awesome.
Whoo.
We got our lawsky.
We've got legends.
Guido versus Bobby Green.
Woo.
Rashad Evans.
Yeah.
There's some good fights.
Real good fights.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's going to be the greatest set of
Itas versus pettis.
God Damn.
Yeah,
this is very good.
Yeah.
Very good.
I really hope not.
Not all these fall through like normal.
Well we have only a month and then it'll
be one holly fighting Romero.
That'll be all this left Robert
Whittaker.
You'll over Merrill is a fucking bang
and fight for Chicago.
God Damn Dose Angeles versus Covington
though.
That's the fight.
Cause Dosantos at one 70 has been a
fucking monster because he's one of
those guys that was cutting so much
weight to make one 55 he just couldn't
take it anymore.
I mean it was just beaten his body up
and then he moves up to one 70 and he
looks like a fucking killer again.
He looks like
a world beater at one 70 and he's been
trying to fight Woodley and he just beat
the shit out of Robbie lawler.
Yeah.
So that's a big fight for him.
And a big fight for colby for the
interim title.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Can't wait.
Chicago,
was it the eighth,
ninth.
June 9th.
I wish I could go into coma until then.
No,
you don't.
Yeah.
You have marathons to run.
Oh,
arrows to shoot.
That's tricky to which,
let's go shoot some arrows.
Let's wrap this up.
All right,
folks.
Michael Chandler will be here on Monday.
I'm gonna tell you who I got.
I got a lot of fucking people going
down.
I got a lot of podcasts this week.
Okay.
Chandler.
Yeah.
I love him too.
Um,
Matt Taibbi will be here this week.
Uh,
my friend Mike Baker,
uh,
I got a lot of shit happening.
All right.
We'll see you soon,
folks.
Love Ya.
Bye.
Hm.